I have a lot of friends that are falling off crazies.
Boom.
And we're live Nick Depaulo.
Yeah.
Good to see you my friend.
I can't believe that Jim out there.
It's nice.
Right?
With the Porsche parked next to it.
You gotta be able to work out where you work.
If you do that,
you get more in next to your Porsche.
Yeah.
Too bad things at working out.
Well for you Joan.
See what you're doing.
And I doing anything I'm going to front.
So we were talking before the podcast and I said saved this cause it's
hilarious.
Yeah.
Randy credico.
Yeah,
it was a stand up comedian has been involved in this Roger Stone thing.
Yes.
As you know,
Roger Stone this morning,
the FBI raided,
you know,
took him out of his house in his pajamas and who I love by Roger Stone
interviewed me on Info wars.
He used to love my radio show on Sirius.
Yeah.
They asked him,
they asked me to get him on and I was like,
Eh,
I think I'm going to duck that one buddy.
He's fucking eccentric and crazy.
He's a loon.
Yeah.
And,
and so this is Randy and they,
they,
they've known each other forever and are they friends while they were real,
all this shit started and uh,
oh,
it's fucking classic.
Randy credit goes radical left.
He used to do,
did a,
um,
a comedy album years ago.
Yeah.
It was him and a bunch of other guys and it was all,
it was all political.
It was like five guys or three a few guys.
I forget how many guys think Cremins was on it.
Oh,
sure.
It's critical.
Yeah.
And uh,
maybe Jimmy tingle.
Yup.
Yeah.
And they had like a whole thing they were doing almost like a,
like a tour,
you know,
and it like super left wing
politically aware.
But this is fucking way back in the day.
I want to say this is the 90s.
They were doing this.
Yeah.
I mean,
he was,
he was always funny.
I mean,
I've watched him die every night at catch a rising star because he's,
he'd be up there doing such inside political shit.
He'd be talking about a bill that was passed that day on the floor or whatever
the fuck,
and the crowd will be staring at him and he had a hot Asian girlfriend and he'd
be dying up there.
This is when I fell in love with them and he goes,
he goes,
that's my girlfriend over there.
I taught her a forwards and English,
not you crowd suck.
I mean,
he was really fucking funny,
but so political and inside and accent.
But he stayed at my apartment when I lived out here in la and he fucking like
try to pick up my wife after I left.
I had to go on the road somewhere,
but I still love him.
He's fucking crazy.
But he,
he sent me a picture of him,
a 2016 in front of the embassy in London where what's his name was?
Held up a sign.
Really?
Yes.
And I'm like,
what the fuck is going on?
What's he doing out there?
And then all that shit came out about wiki leaks and stuff.
So they thought he might've been the intermediary.
Yeah.
So he's gone in front of Roger Stone,
gone in front of model or a couple of times and,
and uh,
so there it is right here.
Who is Randy credico
threatened to take away apartment,
uh,
Sochi.
His dog,
if he cooperated with Russia,
investigate what he threatened to take away his dog.
Oh,
fucking you gotta to read the texts that Roger Stone,
they're public I think would send to Randy.
I'm going to take your dog.
Oh yeah.
He goes,
let's get it on.
Beat the prayer to die.
I'm going to take your fucking,
that's why I love this guy.
This guy had a Nixon Tattoo when he was 18 on his back.
I just don't do it.
He marched in the gay parade in New York.
I fucking love him.
He's nuts.
Why do marching and getting creative in New York?
Just pro gay,
right?
Well,
he's pro just,
yeah.
You know,
so he's just all over the place.
He's all over the place,
but he's a right,
I mean,
get a Nixon Tac toe,
right fucking right wing.
But uh,
all the right wing people to get a look at this.
That is so ridiculous.
The fucking mix it,
that's a good tattoo too.
I never did that.
And I got 60 something years old,
but at least,
and he loved my radio show on Sirius and,
and he,
uh,
he did,
he hosted info was,
it was about six months ago.
He had me on as a guest when I got punched in the face by that broad oh,
that's right.
I forgot about.
So,
uh,
so yeah,
they rated the FBI,
raided his house,
took him out today and that he got out on to $250,000 bond.
And um,
he,
he wanted credit co,
you know,
to stop contesting what,
what stone said in front of when he testified.
So Coco said that's not how it went down by bus.
So they are fighting and shit and then he's threatening them.
And um,
but uh,
yeah,
I Randy,
so I text Randy today.
I go,
I'm doing Rogan.
I mean,
if you want to walk away.
And he's like,
well,
call me before the show,
let me know.
He goes,
there's not too much I can say right now.
But what's funny is I know both these guys that is so weird and he said,
yeah,
let me know.
He goes,
I can't say much because they just just arrested the FBI.
They you,
they're going to turn.
They try to,
I see what Paula is doing.
He's turning Roger Stone against Trump.
Trump is the target,
so he's going to threaten him with it.
You know,
he's 60 something years old so he could spend the rest of his life in prison or
talk,
you know,
he's doing that with every,
he's a scary guy.
Mahler.
If he,
if you had a problem and that guy was coming after,
you shouldn't get mad at God because he's going to do it slow.
Like by the time this actually gets handled,
Trump,
he's going to be,
I don't think they do that slow.
They do.
I think that's different than anyway.
I'm very confused by the time they get to Trump.
He's already so nerve racked,
you know what I'm saying?
Because he liked chips away at his borders,
like slowly but surely takes away all the people around him.
Yeah.
He gets closer and you know,
you know,
you know he's concentrating on the family,
you know.
Well,
of course,
of course.
Of course.
That's what he does.
And even does that with people like stone.
He'll go after your family and stuff and you notice you never hear a word out of
Ivanka anymore.
No,
exactly.
Yeah,
yeah.
Guarantee you,
guarantee you they scared the fuck out of her.
But if you want to know about Mala,
like you said and how
fucking creepy he is,
he was the head of the FBI during the eighties of the Whitey Bulger Shit went
down and he put four guys in it.
Listen to this,
Joe,
and this,
you can look this up.
This isn't me.
Four guys,
he put in prison and wrongly it turns out two of them died in prison.
Whoa.
Yeah.
You can go go because of Bulger.
And it had to do with that because they would do things in the FBI would let
them get away with it because they were providing informations.
Right.
That was the whole,
exactly right.
And he fought.
Two guys died in prison.
Wrongly,
by the way,
this guy's not a fucking good guy.
No,
he's a marine and decorated marine and shit.
They make those sacrifices.
They make those decisions where they're just going to like help a person who is
a criminal because they're criminals providing information that can allow them
to get more criminal large,
wide.
He was providing all kinds of shit about the guineas and he spots.
That was a great movie too,
by the way.
Nice to train a guy who was one of the whities hitman.
Dana.
Why?
No,
no,
no.
To the Teanaway stay like a threatened,
he had to move out of town.
It was a ball.
Joe Baltar related.
Yes.
It was both elated.
When I was teaching taekwondo,
I had one of the guys that was in my class,
it was whacking people for what he calls her and he was asking me,
if you want to kill somebody with your bare hands,
where would you hit him?
I was like,
oh,
the neck.
I was like 18.
I was like,
oh.
He goes,
correct.
Ya look good.
Yeah.
I like that.
What was it,
Kevin?
Uh,
no,
no.
But you know,
Kevin,
you know,
he went away to this,
um,
now the tough kid.
Yeah.
All related.
All of them together,
you know.
Um,
this guy was a different guy.
This guy was,
he went away too.
But I mean,
he went away forever.
He was one of those guys,
like they caught them blood under his fingernails and he was working with white.
Yeah.
Well,
there's a lot of guys that were,
I mean,
it was a big organization.
And when,
when we were kids,
I mean,
everybody knew it was a big org.
it wasn't,
it wasn't a fucking secret.
Oh No.
Oh,
I know.
How did Hannity's attempt to link Mower to Whitey Bulger?
Hold up this article in the Boston Globe says that's not true.
Whatever.
It's the FBI and he wasn't,
there wasn't there,
wasn't there then.
Oh,
he wasn't at the FBI.
Yeah.
It says lower serve the US attorney's office in Boston from 82 to 88,
his chief of the criminal division,
first assistant us attorney and acting us attorney from weathered a year.
During that time,
Bolger ran a sprawling criminal enterprise and got away with murders because he
was a longtime FBI informant who corrupted his handlers.
The FBI.
He corrupted his handlers.
I love it.
And the FBI and the New England organized crime strike force,
a prosecutor prosecutorial unit that worked independently in the US Attorney's
office,
uh,
reportedly,
reported directly to the Justice Department.
Use Bulgur to build cases against the mafia and give him a pass on its own
crimes.
The FBI is corrupt.
Relationship with Bulger was exposed after he was indicted on federal
racketeering charges in 1995 became a fugitive.
He was captured 16 years later,
I would hear,
you know,
so,
uh,
yeah,
it was captured in Santa Monica.
And,
uh,
so when did,
Mueller says,
did mujer know the men have been wrongly convicted
and look the other way?
There's nothing linking Mujer to that case.
According to several attorneys for,
for the men volume as court records and a former federal judge who presided over
their wrongful imprisonment trial in 2007 the US District Judge Nancy Gertner
found the FBI deliberately withheld evidence at the foremen were innocent.
The bureau help cover up the injustice for deck cheese cries.
I fucking hate read and shit like that.
She ordered the government to pay the men and their families 101.7 million.
Okay,
maybe worth it.
How
long did you guys go away for?
Let's be honest,
you're never going to make a hundred millions chicken scratch too.
They all got 100 million.
If every one of them got 100 million,
I mean I'm,
I'm in.
I mean how much time you have to do?
How many times do you get fucked where you're in jail?
How's it per load?
Fuck man.
So maybe it was just a rumor that he was a part of that.
Well,
like you said though,
let's they FBI,
she has a story,
broke them,
showed they call the paper and said,
listen,
get your facts straight.
Well,
how crazy is it?
The FBI covered up the information and knew those guys were innocent.
That is dark.
Who went to jail for that?
Did the guys who covered it up go to jail?
I'm not sure,
but uh,
two of them died.
You can't,
they died in jail.
Two of them died in jail.
Oh.
You know they caught him because his wife was yelling and shit all the time.
Yeah,
she was cocoa.
He had fucking cash on the walls and shit.
Did He,
I used to sell dope,
meet door to door when I,
before I started comedy and I used to go to fucking went the hell,
not one where I was.
And I would,
I would want the,
why people would look at my,
I take out my shit and the that's slapped that break sound like 40 bucks a pop,
get the fuck out.
And then somebody explained to me,
you know what the hell is like,
why he bolts?
Wow.
So you were selling meat and his neighbor fucking same in East Boston.
I knocked at the door,
a couple of guys and revere that we'll get like fucking connected.
My Buddy Al know who they were and shit later on.
Well they probably knew people from meatpacking.
They've probably gotten it off the boats of course.
And I'm like,
I'm doing my little spiel there for a boy.
Look,
you know,
a fucking boiler room operation.
Now you break it down per meal,
it comes out,
they're three bucks a meeting.
And they had done the math in the head.
You could tell they were like bookies,
you know,
they like 40 bucks a pump,
get the fuck up.
My steps wasn't really that much.
Well it was ridiculous,
you know.
But uh,
and I was in Rhode Island,
uh,
banging doors and,
and,
and uh,
I got the same response and I looked down and I see in the streets,
the lines of the streets are red,
white,
and green.
I was in federal hill and providence with a mafia style.
Look at that sign article.
Look at this Whitey Bulger.
Santa Monica hideout was full of money.
It's still brims with mystery.
He was living in like a normal apartment.
I know.
So weird.
He had $822,000 in cash and valuables.
Wow.
Jesus Christ.
I liked that movie.
I thought Johnny Depp was great now.
Yeah,
he was.
He was great in it.
Yeah.
That's a creepy dude.
He was as creepy as they get.
It's amazing how much corruption was involved in that case.
Yes.
And the federal government was a part of it and they let that monster,
they let them thrive.
Yeah.
So makes you wonder about the FBI today.
Well,
it should make you want,
it shows you what they're capable of it.
That way.
Whenever you're doing that,
whenever you're allowing someone to commit murder and deal drugs to get other
people that are committing murder and dealing drugs,
like what?
Because they would just want it.
They just look what happens with cops in this is very unfortunate,
but this is just is just what happens when you have a a game and the game is
arrest people.
The game is when,
right.
You have a certain amount of calls you have to make and if you could make more
callers because you're in bed with a bad guy,
especially if maybe you grew up in that neighborhood,
it's always been kind of an accepted part of that neighborhood.
That Guy Conley grew up with one.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
It makes a sneaky little deal.
Yeah,
it was Sam,
it lawyers.
It's all about you have to have,
it's like sports.
You have to have a winning record.
You're not going to succeed.
So they play outside the rules.
I mean that's one of the reasons why cops and people have such a weird
relationship because they're always looking to arrest people and [inaudible]
cops talking to him like,
ah,
I don't put me on your record,
I'm on.
And they just,
Oh,
maybe I can get you for something.
I got to get somebody.
And I know when they have quotas,
like when you have quote,
like what would,
what would the police force do if nobody broke crimes anymore?
Did make shit up.
If they,
what would they do?
Like legitimately,
if they really do,
that would never happen.
It would never happen.
But what if everybody got on mushrooms and the world,
the world got cleaned up.
I was wondering how long it would take to get there.
Not much.
How much time can we get a couple of years ago?
I mean in the compensation to mushrooms.
I got some right here.
If you want some dude,
I can't even handle regular mushrooms.
Fucking chance.
Shataki make me crazy.
I don't know how you'd do that shit.
We discussion DMT and Portabello Nice glaze.
Demi glaze on it.
Yeah,
it just,
it though the hole.
I mean the,
the music thing is very,
it's very interesting.
It's very interesting because you're watching a professional like cast a web
like nice and slow.
Nice and slow with the full force of the FBI against you.
And if the,
they would against a rod,
just don't,
like I said,
they'll do,
you know it's creepy.
Well,
Jamie said they opened up the government today to distract from the fact that
Roger Stone got arrested.
Most likely.
I think you're right.
I think that's a good assessment,
I guess.
Eh,
I mean top trumps the final target.
So,
um,
but yeah,
he's gonna,
he's gonna threaten stone with,
you know,
he's like 66.
Yeah.
Threatens them with 10 years.
He's probably gonna.
Yeah.
He's kind of just enough to fucking make,
I'm sang,
but he's such a sing song.
Like Dershowitz says they don't just sang.
They,
they uh,
they actually,
uh,
how did Dershowitz put it?
They actually,
and I'll come up with the lyrics they create.
They don't just sing.
Yeah.
You know,
what do you think is going to happen to Trump if you had a yes.
As far as this investigation?
Nothing really pass other coffee over here.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Thanks brother.
Why do you think nothing's going to happen?
Is that,
well that's not true.
I shouldn't say that because only because I think Molly's pretty fucking evil
and it will come up with something.
Well,
you know what?
Impeachment at the,
at the worst,
but where's the high crimes and misdemeanors?
What?
Well,
if there's obstruction of justice,
if there was collusion,
if there was any sort of,
if they can prove that there was some sort of concerted effort to undermine
democracy.
Yeah.
Which I don't think I,
I don't think they'll get to get that.
Even with Roger Stone,
they're not charging him with collision.
A conspiracy just lying and covering up.
They don't,
they don't have them for collusion.
Oh,
conspiracy.
They're lying and covering up the,
uh,
interactions with Russians.
Right.
So what it is,
I guess that would be lists angle.
Yeah.
No,
Jamie was talking about something yesterday and I started listening to this
recent Sam Harris' podcast and it is fucking fascinating how much Russian troll
farms and all these fake accounts and what they're trying to do.
And one of the things they're trying to do is what Jamie was saying was that
that kid with the mag a hat with a native American beat the drum in front of
them.
The image of that was posted by this website that turned out to be a Russian
troll farm,
but it was in Brazil.
Was it Jane as a blogger in Brazil?
Yeah.
When they'd,
CNN looked into it,
they just kind of asked Twitter what's going on with this account.
And by the time they'd asked them,
they just suspended that council.
It's gone.
But,
but you said they suspended account because the account was a fake account.
They had a,
they thought it was posing as like a California teacher and as Telia,
but it was,
it was an actual blogger and Brazil.
Oh,
so it was Brazil wasn't rushing.
No,
I wasn't sure it was sewn into a fake account if someone's,
but yes,
they saw some seeds of,
yeah,
well they're trying to get people against each other.
They're doing that in a minute.
Like people need to understand that this is actually really happening and we
need their help.
Hurley,
what we do and against each other day,
we need the Russians help.
Well,
if you stop and think about it,
has there ever been a time with the left and the right were more,
it chose throats and ends enough?
You don't need rush
was Arabic,
but are CNN enough to really get people turned against each other like this?
No fucking way.
You need angry discourse online.
And the way that comes from,
there's [inaudible],
there's an amazing Radiolab podcast about this where they talked to people that
actually worked in these troll farms and that these people were,
they would both be left wing and right wing and is one of the things that
they're talking about on the Sam Harris' podcast.
It's,
I think it's called a war of information,
but they'll pose as like a pro choice people and say ridiculous shifts like over
the top.
Ridiculous.
And then they'll pose is life American flag.
And you know,
Magda in the,
in the,
you know,
the Hashtag and there they're heading,
but they have nothing to do with that.
They're just Russians and they're just trying to get people riled up.
And you see people jump on board.
Oh,
Shyman in.
But,
um,
I was talking to a comic that we were talking about that I won't bring his name
up,
but he referred me to this,
this Russian guy.
I can't add a mock of Bremmer's name,
but this is a clip of this Russian guy who worked for the KGB defected over
here.
And he was explaining how Russia does that.
Yeah,
and this was back in the 80s Oh,
well,
we do it too.
Everybody does it.
They all do it.
They fuck with the system in any way,
shape or form in order to achieve a desired result.
I think the Russians are the best at it,
apparently.
Well,
I just think they're way more dedicated to it and then,
yeah,
I mean it's a sneaky way to go about doing things too because Russia doesn't
have the,
the kind of money that the United States,
so they got nothing they had out there.
Their economies the size of Texas.
Yeah.
All's I have is nuclear weapons there.
Almost like a third world and a brutal dictator.
A dictator.
Yeah.
That's all it takes.
But as a far as the economy and everything,
they're like a third world she had.
Yeah.
It's,
well,
they're like a small European country,
but it's really interesting when you,
you listen to these podcasts about how much effort they put into sewing
discourse or discord to getting people upset with each other,
to starting arguments and to saying things that are going to upset people in
order to get the right versus the left.
Yeah.
To like,
sure.
To undermine democracy from the inside.
Yeah.
It's really interesting.
I mean it's,
it's weird that it works,
but it makes sense that it works.
It's a sneaky ass strategy.
Yeah.
You think CNN does just as good a job.
They really do harm,
but you're so,
you're so right wing.
You can't.
I'm not so right when Zhao right wing.
All right.
Middle,
middle,
right.
I'd say center right of center.
Right.
Of Center,
right.
Of Center.
Yeah.
What's wrong with CNN?
Do you like it?
First of all,
I don't need to hear it.
And every fucking airport or if I'm doing a Gig last fucking words,
I want to hear her wolf blitzer before my plane crashes.
Um,
somebody told me Wolf Blitzer got on jeopardy and they exposed them.
Yes,
I remember reading that because you know,
people get on television,
they read off a teleprompter.
You think they're brilliant,
they seem brilliant,
and then you get them alone.
About Louis goes on a jeopardy and winds.
What Lucy did he remember they have celebrities on once in a while.
When did you do that?
A couple of years ago.
Did he go on with regular people in when I forget who he's against.
I think it was other famous paper.
That makes sense.
Jonathan dropped.
Well,
he's a very smart,
well do you remember he went on jeopardy against regular people time.
Yeah.
He won the whole tournament.
A comic.
So folks don't take us light less.
He still right for there.
He has wolf blitzer minus 4,000 dumb ass.
Yeah.
It didn't work out so well.
Ah,
fuck.
Good Fun.
It is hilarious.
Well,
you know,
people can pretend to be smart.
You know,
you read all these Shell prompter,
they give you the script,
you know.
But John was Jonathan Groff.
Does he still write for Conan?
It's a good question.
Don't know.
The last time I saw him.
Uh,
but he was fucking really,
really bright.
Funny Guy Too.
And really funny.
Yeah.
I don't think he does stand up anymore though.
Lead just rights.
That's how smart he is.
He's like enough of this nonsense is jokey joke.
Non said enough is enough.
I'm starting to feel that way.
Um,
but why,
why do you hate CNN?
I'll come on all the fucking shit they put out there.
And uh,
just an example,
how about before the one went,
Donna Brazil had the notes for Hillary before the fucking Barney.
Yes.
Remember that this credit you CNN was,
she was a pond it right.
And they still had a run.
That's what's coming to us that they had her on after that.
He told Dale questions we're going to be,
yeah.
Well her book was amazing though,
that that's what's interesting is they fucked her over and then she came in
notebook and then rip them.
Ooh,
is there,
I have it.
I haven't read it yet.
Put the,
what I read about how they rigged the DNC.
This is how they,
how they,
uh,
Fuck Bernie out of the primaries.
Yeah.
Woo.
Bernie gets screwed.
It's a dark business.
Fucking,
it's all the same.
They're all in coach.
But you don't think like the mainstream media is a little like a propaganda arm
for the Democratic Party.
Well,
they did 93% negative coverage.
They definitely think they're working for the good,
but it's only 3% negative coverage with Trump.
Trump is an,
you know,
he's an unusually polarizing figure.
Sure.
I mean,
was it that way with,
um,
well I guess it was probably pretty negative with Bush all.
It was a different world back then.
No,
it was,
but they always,
since I've been a kid,
I mean Reagan was a dummy and just to fucking be actor and an idiot,
no racist.
You can look at the ship year after year.
That's true.
George Bush,
senior George W.
Bush,
Dick Cheney warmonger but it's the same shit.
Racist,
bigot race and it works.
And Ford,
Ford was a moron and Ford was my,
about how he's portrayed on SNL and he was always falling down.
I couldn't walk three feet,
which was kind of true,
actually.
Got It.
And he was an athlete when it,
but it's always been that way.
So the mainstream media has always sort of a more liberal,
and I'll write,
but then you have Fox News,
which goes far the other way.
What would their opinion shows?
But at least when you watch Fox News,
which everybody who hates Fox,
who's never watches it,
number one,
uh,
but,
but they at least have liberals on and Shepard Smith,
yes and hates.
Yes he does.
He looks like every guy that bullied them as a kid.
Do you think that's why I ate something?
I do.
That's it.
That's the only reason.
The only way to nothing.
And that's the reason most of them hate him.
He said,
here's what's not,
here's what they don't bring up.
Even Hannity and all these guys,
you get your head going like a passion wants change a second that he's getting
irritated with me already.
I got to get you out of La.
I'm afraid you're going to get disease.
Uh,
and everything's good over nine.
Now.
Tell me about it.
Uh,
but uh,
what,
what were you just talking about?
Why they hate Trump?
Because they never bring up this though.
They never cause he's a alpha male,
blonde haired,
blue eyed fucking billionaire.
That is the,
that's the embodiment of the devil for the left.
They never bring that up on the shelf.
That's really what it is,
is nothing to do with him lying all the time.
And that's nothing to do with it.
What's he lie about the number of people at his inauguration as opposed to Obama
going,
oh,
you can keep your healthcare.
I mean the fucking,
you know,
he doesn't lie any more than any other president.
You don't think so?
If he does,
it's trivial shit.
He's a salesman.
He's a,
there's a fine line,
but it's definitely a salesman.
But Oh,
he's a bullshit.
But that's what we need.
We're a cooperation where corporate the countries don't think so.
That's what I always heard.
It's kind of like that little bit.
I mean,
it's some,
some sort of an organization.
He really is.
Hillary Clinton Lion.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Well,
why don't you get called on it?
How's that fat Twat not in cups.
Oh,
how dare you.
It is.
Good question.
You know?
Yeah,
it's a great question.
I was talking to Mike Baker who used to work for the CIA.
Oh,
I'd buy it.
Met My fucking web guy.
No,
because he,
he wanted to come out here with me and Mike Baker from the CIO is if he,
if he did anything remotely like what Hillary did,
he'd be in jail for 30 years.
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
I remember the kid in the submarine that worked for the Navy,
but he took pictures of the submarine.
I mean he like took a selfie and it had bad shit in the background that it
wasn't supposed to take photos off.
And how long was he in jail?
I don't know.
So I would just like to see some equity as far as people being held accountable
on both sides.
That's how maybe it would have been different if Hillary made it through.
Maybe it would have been different in terms of like media coverage.
If she actually became president out,
they would have sucked her ass.
You're there as song.
Yeah,
I think so.
I don't know man.
Once Donna Brazile's book came out and people have an understanding about the
inner workings of the Party,
I mean I think look it politics or it's dirty,
dirty business.
Phillip Day stirred,
he's worse than podcast,
but podcasts are pretty clean tie.
No,
like relatively,
but it's very quick.
That's why people come to it.
Yeah.
You can't get the truth from mainstream media.
While I was trying to explain to a friend who was talking about doing a podcast,
a deal with a network and I was like,
stop.
You can't this the one thing that you can have where you can,
it can be mainstream and it's free of everything.
Free of any influence.
And you're going to let a bunch of pen,
pencil pushers and button pressers.
They're gonna tell you what you can and can't say which direction you can and
can't go.
You know they're going to try to influence you.
But isn't Google doing that now?
What do you mean with conservatives?
Like shutting down Dennis Prager
as like a fucking,
what do you mean good fire as well?
Youtube is owned by go about a company.
Okay.
What I'm talking about a company,
you going into business with them and you can wear your a podcast,
you're free and independent.
It's probably the only thing in the world where you can be completely free and
independent and still reach millions of people.
It really is the only thing in the world.
But how,
what is Google doing?
What I'm saying?
Google owns youtube,
right,
right.
And uh,
people like Dennis Prager religious right guy is his shall get shut down on
Youtube.
What do you mean it's shut down?
They shut it.
That he's suing.
He's showing fucking gold bill.
I didn't know about this.
Yeah,
I know.
He does those shows with a Corolla Corolla to listen to him.
And I lived in La.
He's a conservative religious Jewish guy.
I've listened to him a hundred.
Yes.
Well they considered hate speech.
I mean that's,
that's when we're getting into a dangerous territory.
Wait a minute,
I pull up,
uh,
what,
what happened to him?
Cause I'm,
I'm completely ignorant about this.
This is the first time I'm hearing about,
oh,
this is going to go to the supreme court.
Really thanks to,
so they pulled it.
So they took his page down.
They said,
you can't have a page on youtube anymore.
Yeah.
They say,
shut the show down.
Do you remember what it was about?
Not specifically,
but I know it was labeled hate.
And if you listen to this guy for 10 minutes,
he's the most congenial,
fair minded,
uh,
you know,
but he's,
he's a,
you know,
a religious guy.
Do you know flying,
do you know Doug was Martinez?
He's actually her who is,
he's a,
he's a a,
an intellectual from England who wrote about,
uh,
wrote a book about immigrants in Europe called the strange death,
I think it's called Islam and the strange death of Europe.
And uh,
he's basically talking about how people from these countries that have emigrated
into Europe are changing the culture,
changing the culture.
And there's all sorts of,
you know,
crimes and things that are happening that didn't exist before and people are
developing these communities of likeminded people that didn't exist prior.
No go zones.
And,
and he's saying that this is,
you know,
this is fundamentally dangerous,
but he's saying it from a point of perspective of understanding the actual facts
involve and talking about the situation and talking about how these are people
that don't respect homosexuals.
They want to throw them off roofs and they have these pages.
They have these opinions about people that are extremely antiquated and not
aligned with European values in the modern Western world.
Right?
The,
he and Sam Harris had a conversation and that conversation got flagged on
Youtube.
Uh,
it got flack as someone put it up in there.
You know,
you make it like a little watch list.
What is it called?
What was it called?
The v the list.
You could,
will you put it on Youtube,
on your channel where you could the playlist.
So he puts it on his playlist and he gets a compute,
uh,
a community guideline strike against him for putting up this conversation
between two intellectuals.
So I,
this conversation with this lady
at Youtube,
and I said,
well,
why,
why would you do that?
Why,
why does that get?
She goes,
well,
it's hate speech.
I go,
it's hate speech of you talking about to intellectuals having a discussion about
a real thing that's happening right now in Europe.
And you're saying hate speech.
If you listen to the podcast,
there's no slurs used.
Just facts.
So just talking about Prego,
but this is,
this was the way she said it,
cause it's hate speech.
I'm like,
you had,
you said that so easily.
Yes.
You'd never seen a lot of power,
but it's also a lot of irresponsible power for the responsible use of power.
But,
but,
but my point is they're cracking down on people who lean,
right?
Whether it's Twitter.
Yes.
It's 100% true.
Yeah.
And that's a big fucking problem.
A hate speech.
We're going to let Google decide,
uh,
what's the name of the company that owns alphabet?
Uh,
they're going to decide what,
what I,
I brought that up on.
I brought that up on a tough crowd years ago about when you disagree with the
liberal or whatever you're arguing with,
they always go,
you're a hater.
They would keep saying that.
And that's what it turned into.
If you dismiss a grade,
you're a hater now it's you're a bigot or a racist.
If you didn't agree with Obama's policies,
your bigot or a racist.
And,
and that shit works that that's been working for the left the years.
But now that the social media,
Google controls almost all the information you are,
you and I hear every day.
I mean,
that's why it's so dangerous.
So look up.
Yeah.
Prager's a as the purse example that comes to mind,
that guy he owes me.
Um,
uh,
yeah,
because he's,
he's,
you know,
a Christian or whatever.
We should,
he's not he
Jewish but,
but you don't get up at it unless,
unless I'm,
what I just read was wrong.
They weren't deleted from Youtube.
At least they weren't deleted.
They were restricted.
Put it like meaning like show up at,
uh,
the adult thing.
Like you have to have an account that says you're 18 or older or something like
that.
And they were fighting and having a lawsuit against that,
saying that what they have in their videos or not shouldn't be behind that,
like that wall,
whatever that is.
They also then,
but this is my point,
you have to go to youtube to get the store,
hold on.
So I'm on their website.
I went to a couple different websites to see it,
but they were also,
like yesterday they had ads blacklisted from Spotify.
So they had ads that were I guess initially approved and now they have been
disapproved and they haven't really explained to them as well.
He's so and soap.
So,
but his page is still up,
you know Corolla,
don't you?
Yeah,
I believe that's come about it.
But the youtube page is still up.
It shows not his show was shut down.
They might have,
they might have taken it down by now.
This is like,
this is kind of from a couple of months ago.
They shot him down.
So if you go to the Dennis Prager youtube channel,
it doesn't exist.
So the idea that they would make that 18 plus because it's conservative.
That's hilarious.
It's up.
This is it.
This is this channel Bro.
Prager u,
yeah,
let's try it.
But it's got a million subscribers.
Million 949 I they brought it back up.
Is that what you're saying?
Maybe
they have a video up from an hour ago.
Spotify,
bands,
Prager from advertising.
Google a lawsuit.
I mean that's what it was about.
It's about them getting angry,
restrict him angry.
Cause we're not getting the full story here.
Well I mean,
not that it's up right now.
It's,
he's uh,
he's still on him.
Yeah,
no,
I believe you.
So my point being is these big tech,
big tech companies,
uh,
crushing conservative,
well here,
most part.
Yes.
And here's a good way to look at it.
If you're going after a guy like Dennis Prager,
who,
again,
it's the most congenial guy,
never swears,
very,
very mild mannered,
very cool and calm and whether you agree with them or disagree with them,
right.
It's not the way to go about something like this if you disagree with someone is
not to shut them down.
I was to have a debate.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And that's not happening.
Well,
you know,
well,
you saw the Google memo.
You saw what happened with that guy when he provided all this information about
one of the reasons why women don't get into tech and they labeled him as Dang a
massage says a woman hater and define like,
no,
he's giving you scientific studies that show that women have different
interests.
Is that Lawrence Summers?
You're talking about this Ben?
A few since Lawrence Summers was actually the president of Harvard and he was
giving a speech and,
and that's all he said he was.
He brought up the numbers as far as males going into science and math.
He didn't say women not good at it and he get fucking canned from Auburn.
Yeah.
You can't have anything that's fascism.
If it disagrees with the orthodoxy,
they'll come down on you.
Even if it's factual like James Damore and you could clearly back it up.
You could look at the actual numbers.
Not only that,
that James to more guy put a page and a half in there on strategies for
encouraging women to get into tech.
I mean if he was a real massage demar Google.
Google,
yes.
He's the Google memo going,
right?
That was what started it off.
These,
all these intellectuals came to his side.
They'll look,
why are we doing all this research?
If you guys completely ignore it every time it comes up,
right?
Like you're pretending that this research is not valid.
This research is,
it's it's scientific information that shows that certain types of people are
more interested in different things.
We've known that forever.
That's why boy toys and girl toys are different because boys and girls like
different shit.
I mean,
it's basically a more complex version of that and he's essentially saying women
like different things.
It doesn't show that.
It can't do both to say.
The only difference between the sexes is Sochi constructed obstacles.
We'll genders gender itself.
It is.
They should come here and take a look at your place.
That would shut them.
Shut the argument.
That's all male,
male,
gender.
I've got some female stuff here from when my kids come over to attempt to tell.
Tell them what you said to me when I say a fucking great place.
Oh,
this is what happens when women don't get to tell you what to do
place.
You have a warehouse of mail,
but this looks,
that's not a nice guy.
That's not bad.
And three courses.
But the problem was in this society,
male energy,
male thinking male,
and he is vilified and you're,
you're taught to think there's something wrong with being masculine.
Being masculine is the reason why we don't speak German.
Okay,
stop.
Exactly.
Talk about toxic masculinity.
Yo could you will be the poster boy for that Shit.
Well,
the whole reason why you need male people is because there's mail people,
other places that will take away your shit and kill your people.
Exactly.
This is not a bad thing.
Male does not equal evil.
Just because there are evil men,
they are evil men.
Doesn't mean all men are evil.
There's evil women too.
It doesn't mean all women are evil dated three of them.
I bet you did it more than three,
let's be honest.
Yeah,
no,
you're absolutely right.
But this toxic masculinity,
that is his fuss.
Solera like you said,
rarely worldwide two.
However,
that turned out well.
There's just so many dumb phrases like that,
you know,
we'll donate up.
Do you know about heteronormative?
I'm sure he knows CIS gendered.
CIS gendered.
Yes.
Hetero normative.
Yeah.
Like you're,
you're imposing the norms.
Like as if heterosexuality is normal.
Well,
did you see,
what was the story a couple days ago and I was in California here.
A beautiful state of California.
They're trying to the heat.
You can't say he or she is they now lat?
Yeah.
Where everywhere.
Uh,
I'm saying that,
I'm saying to Hannah something Jackson.
He,
uh,
yeah.
Now you have to say they nope.
And they were passing it.
They had her in the,
the meeting,
uh,
the actual,
town hall.
A city.
Where are they passing the ordinance and at the end she goes,
my,
my grandma,
my grammar teacher wouldn't approve of that.
She's rolling around her,
but we won't hear from her.
She said her and somebody called her out on it as she was passing the left wing.
Nonsense.
You shouldn't buy your grandmother.
She's not here.
It was corrected identification.
Of course.
She looked like Newt Gingrich.
There she is,
California state senator bans.
The use of he and she during committee hearings.
Oh look at her with her perfect fucking liberal haircut.
No Gingrich's haircut,
pow.
It's facing.
Some people are just hilarious,
but they called her out.
She's trying to do a good thing though is you know,
and uh,
that Colorado,
they had a laugh about it,
but uh,
that is so funny.
What the fuck does she look like?
Oh my God.
We wouldn't be hearing from her.
Well,
you made me dress was an interrupted by listeners who corrected her usage and
demand.
Oh,
stop,
go back.
Corrected her usage and demand that she used the word they or them,
they demanded.
See this is the problem with all this shit.
It's demanding.
They're trying to control people.
They're telling people what to do and what not to do.
And it's about power.
A lot of this stuff is power as they're imposing their worldview on,
on you.
But it's not even their worldview.
It's not real.
What it is,
is they're just deciding that this is a thing that they're going to agree to and
they're going to force other people to comply.
It's half the game.
Half the game is just getting people to comply.
Well,
you do that by,
and you start with language,
you control people's behavior through language,
which is the definition of political.
Yes.
Well that's what Carlin always said that fascism is just political correctness
with good manners are political correctness is fascism with good manners.
Yeah.
How about,
you saw the clip of Louie at governors when he was talking about this,
how the,
you know,
the millennials or whoever demanding what we call them.
Yes.
They are them I,
and he goes,
okay,
I'm,
Louis Goes,
okay,
I'm a location.
It's your mother's con
man.
He goes,
I got to come up with something more clever.
Not as harsh one.
Yeah,
I'm a location.
Your mother's of,
yeah.
What did you think about all that stuff getting leaked?
Well,
but Louise,
you know Stan,
Stan hope at a really good point about that.
But what does he say,
Doug?
He was saying like,
look,
if this was a movie and if you took that movie and filmed it in the movie
theater and then put it online,
you'd be a,
you'd go to jail.
That's right.
You're a criminal,
you're stealing,
you're exposing your,
you're ruining his work.
Yes,
but they think they can ruin his work cause he jerked off in front of some
people.
I don't even know if it's that,
I don't even know if the person that leaked it like was a Louis hater.
Sometimes he makes a fan.
They were laughing hard.
They had to phone in their table.
I was at,
it wasn't governors,
it was the brokerage,
which is the same owners few years ago.
And I'm up there doing my shit and working on a new hour.
I looked on and the kid about 56th row,
I see him,
I see the red light.
Yeah.
And he's got his head down.
So I come down off the stage,
he doesn't even hear me and I grabbed the phone out of his hand.
Ah,
deleted.
I go dude you came out cause you're a fan of mine.
Right.
I go the problem,
I explained it to him and the whole crowd.
The problem with this is if you put this shit online,
I'm working on new,
that's old material.
Right.
You're burning my shit.
You get it.
Yeah.
It's all the other fans that listened to it for sure.
And also it's not fair because these bits are never done.
Like if you want to release it half baked,
like when when you first start working on a bit,
you have a premise,
you got kind of an idea where it's going hoarse.
Yeah.
And then it eventually becomes a bit that you would put on a special,
right?
Yeah.
And they'd get it halfway or a quarter and it'll look shitty and it's all if
it's done,
if you're doing a bit that's complete.
Yeah.
They,
it becomes old without some of the things that people were saying about Louie
that the material's sloppy.
It's not like his old stuff.
He,
yeah,
he's working shit.
I feel old stuff.
You saw when it was done,
like if you came to the store and saw him working on a set like a few years
back,
you would see the same kind of stuff.
I got a couple of comments like that when I put my last special out there.
Like,
well he's doing the same stuff.
Well,
you came out to see me eight 10 months ago when I was working on it.
Yeah,
it's,
it's something in process.
They don't understand though.
Cause it seems like when you're onstage and you're camping up to toppy of and
head and it seems like you're doing something that they can do.
You're just talking,
oh,
I know.
You just talk and I could talk.
It's like there's no other art form like that where it's just talking.
That's exactly right.
Nobody yells at a concert,
nobody sh oh that fucking,
you know,
I could play bass better than that jerk off,
but it stand up
so people have,
you know,
because people have made their friends laugh.
I think Seinfeld solid in a book years ago because you know,
you make your friends laugh,
everybody's made their friends laugh with a comic and I,
and you're like,
I can do,
I call people out when they look bored with me or they have their arms folded.
I go do it.
You've got that smug look on your face.
I know you could do this too,
but you'd rather work at the fucking mattress factory 80 hours a week,
making fucking $400 this is people that they're working at the mattress factory
right now.
Listening to this going,
man.
Fuck you Nigga.
Fuck them.
Whoa.
Hey,
how about you just ignore the guy that's $2,000 for a mattress.
You can weird.
Well,
I know I'll make a mattress.
How much can I pay you to make a mattress?
I don't know.
What am I getting it?
[inaudible] Alice tonight and San Diego Pike.
I have to pay you a lot of money to build me a mattress.
But you said it.
Go find the phase you have to pay for the phone.
That would be it should all together get the fuck outta here.
You can get a mattress.
Be Easy.
Lasers.
I get farm laying all over the house.
Start with my wife's boobs.
Oh,
come on Joe.
When he get this coffee,
it's fucking delicious.
Good.
Where?
I think this is black rifle,
black rifle off that name.
It's a racist.
Oh,
it's not so gun metal.
It's a company of veterans.
It makes the coffee.
Yeah.
Veteran owned black.
Right.
But fuck yeah,
Matt flags veteran on to confessional own company.
I got a flag.
They sent me a,
when I did the Afghanistan USL thank guy sent me a flag that they used in
battle.
Nice.
You have it folded up and I had it hanging but then I made a gym out of my
fucking whatever.
So I don't know where it is.
Oh,
we should probably find it.
I should probably put it back up.
Shouldn't I?
So I brought that up.
Don't worry about it.
Um,
the Louis C K set,
you know,
was very similar in my opinion,
to all the shit that he did before he got in trouble.
But that's solely very similar.
Same kind of material.
The same way he does things.
I mean,
people forget that this is a guy who went on Saturday night live and did a joke
about pedophilia,
pedophiles and about,
you know,
maybe we should like,
let them get away with it so they don't kill your kids.
I mean there's,
it's fucked up.
It's a fucked up bit.
But he was the darling of the left back then and so,
and is allowed to get away with that.
Yes.
If he tried to do that same material,
if he hadn't done that then and instead did that,
now people would be fucking horrified.
What is it Joe,
about offending women or today's feminist?
What they are at the,
in my opinion,
all this political correctness that we hate so much shutting down.
They are at the core,
but,
well,
p did the,
I say this,
the,
the Zeitgeists of the times,
it's like a
fat chicks emotion.
Wow.
Very sensitive.
Uh,
you can't,
you can't cross them.
But it's also because people are realizing now that they can make an impact.
Like one of the things that I read because he's doing this thing in Pittsburgh,
he was doing the Improv and Pittsburgh and this lady who wrote the article wrote
that he's making people put their cell phones in bags.
Much like comedians,
Dave Chappelle and Joe Rogan do.
She used my name to you did that.
I've done it before,
but I only did it when I was filling my Netflix special.
So I didn't want people putting the material out or right before I was releasing
the special and then afterwards I decided it was too much of a pain in the ass.
But the only reason why I was doing it w w had nothing to do with that.
She said because they know words can offend and they don't want the
consequences.
Well I'm going to put it on Netflix,
it's going to be out to the public.
It's offensive.
It's going to,
if you're looking to get offended,
go watch Netflix special.
There's plenty in there for you.
But I need to be able to do it correctly.
Like I'm,
I'm,
I want to work it out so that it has the maximum amount of laughs with the
minimum amount of,
of people getting it the wrong way.
Right.
So this,
it's all about wording and sitting upright and listening to it and go,
maybe there's a better way and you can't do that if somebody releases your shit.
And so these people that don't know comedy and they're saying this like you have
no idea what the process is like,
you just don't.
And if you,
if you do,
you would respect it and appreciate it.
Right,
and the people that are comics that don't respect and appreciate the process,
like that's where we are now,
but it's just because people can make an impact.
They can have a reaction just like the people yelling at her,
you know that she said,
she said,
oh my grandmother would be rolling over in her grave,
say day in them.
Say they're using them,
they're just trying to get a reaction from you.
They're just trying to push buttons.
They're just knowing that they can say something and they can have some sort of
an impact.
We're going to get Louis C K band from here.
You know,
we're going to get nick depalo kicked out of this club.
You can't come to this club.
You've talked negatively about women and women's empowerment and that's
dangerous to girls.
I only get kicked out of one place.
Of course,
one of the best clubs in the country.
What club then comedy work you got kicked out of the comedy works.
I saw like 20 something years ago for what will,
it was a batch,
right party ruining the middle guys set the Mc set and then I went up my second
time there.
I think that's a great club obviously.
And they started yelling shit out.
Like take off,
get Shag deck.
That guy.
And I said,
can we throw these fat cats out?
And it turns out a fat client was running a club so I was picked out of it.
Hey,
well that's how I feel Joe.
Well I was thrown out because of my words.
Well and I get kicked off the smell on onstage and rooster feathers.
Those are the only two places.
Yeah,
I think that was a long time ago though,
right?
I'm smoking on stage.
Oh it was the last time you smoked on stage?
Oh,
a couple weeks ago.
How the fat black pussy cat.
Do you smoke still?
Well you say still,
I just really,
I was,
I
1520 years ago I was a social smoker because everyone need the comedy cellar.
We gotta be sitting across from Mattel breathing in his shit and I'm like,
I might as well put a filter on my mouth and uh,
so you know,
I'd have one at two,
but then I really pick up the pace about a year ago.
What the fuck is that?
Keeps the pounds.
Huh?
What Joe?
It's not dangerous than steroids.
It's not,
I don't know.
I just know I like it but uh,
but uh,
always do.
Oh I do.
Yeah.
What kind of you smoke Marlboro Lights.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh,
was gentle it.
The lights.
Well I'll take cancer light.
You Get a light tumor?
Yeah.
You get to,
how many are you smoking a day?
Half a pack.
Really Do,
you're too smart for that.
That's outrageous.
Oh Joe,
please.
You are can't kill me at camp now.
Wow.
My grandfather smoked pall malls unfiltered and Campbell's,
yeah,
you can't kill it to Paula.
I do 56.
Yeah,
I do it.
My Act though,
cause my friends go,
why don't we just start at this age?
And I go,
why?
Why would you start your 20 so he could have have asked cancer in your forties
I'm timing it out.
Mm.
I see.
If a doctor tells me I have cancer in 25 years,
I'm going to kiss him on the lips.
You see the look.
Some guys in their eighties they look happy.
They're like,
I wish I smoked when I was a fucking kid.
I knew you would have disapproved.
Sad for you is true.
I did that you call removed.
Yeah,
no,
exactly.
I'd rather call this guy.
I get the,
I'm very vain.
I don't want to be that lady.
It looks like
I don't want to be that bridge.
She was so cute when she was young.
You receive?
Yes,
and then she turned out the pop by wow.
Would the voice and everything,
but I'll,
I'll kick it.
Yeah.
You stopped juicing.
Not juicing.
I take testosterone replacement there.
Why do my doctor don't need it?
That's how I,
you say I don't need it.
That's why I don't need it because I do it if I don't do it.
The day before you started doing your old man,
excuse me.
Trust me if I can get you on it.
Go to a doctor,
they get your hormone levels to do it tomorrow and I'll quit the cigarettes.
Quit the cigarettes.
Promise.
Yeah,
I do need it.
I mean I destroyed my shoulders playing football and then I have aches and pains
and uh,
but uh,
you know,
I'm five,
uh,
five 90,
three quarters to 13.
That's not too bad.
That's not bad.
Dude.
You make the Italian thickness and I work out density bro.
I got the shoulders density.
Um,
but this is the biggest I've ever seen.
You,
I've been working out a lot.
Plus it haven't been running cause I had some stem cells shot into my knee.
Oh,
you barely.
Yeah,
I've had some uh,
uh,
a meniscus issues and um,
I,
I'm a fucking idiot.
I can't let him sit.
I,
I've got stem cells before and it felt good.
And then I run miles in the hills every day.
A week later.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
I have,
I have slight a arthritis in both knees.
Yeah.
Well,
stem cells help.
That definitely does.
There's,
there's a bunch of different things you could do to help that before it gets
real bad.
But,
uh,
one of the things they're doing in Panama,
and I sent my mom down there to a doctor Neil Riordan cause very good.
Yeah.
Do you know he is?
No,
no,
no.
He,
I had him on a show with,
uh,
with Mel Gibson and Mel Gibson's dad was 92 when he went down there.
He's in a wheelchair.
It was all fucked up.
Eight years in,
he walks out a hundred years old.
He's fine.
He's a hundreds,
108 years old.
That's what happens when you're 92 and live eight more years.
Thanks for doing the math.
And that's what happened to him.
He yells,
shut out.
You can,
you can say racist shit.
You get it off your chest.
He lived to a hundred.
Well,
it's only the booze that makes them racist.
I know.
Fucking guy's my hero.
Fucking love Mel Gibson.
He's as he ever made a bad movie.
Um,
I mean,
made it himself.
Maybe coming a few shit,
shit,
movies,
toxic masculinity right there.
I liked Apocalypto.
I thought that was great.
A lot of people shit on that and it was right up your alley.
Yeah,
I loved it.
exactly.
I'm,
I'm fascinated with that.
I wish,
I wish I was apart.
No,
I loved that movie.
I,
you know,
I think he's a,
he's a very intense,
very unusual eccentric guy.
Like just being around him,
you,
you get this sense of his energy.
It's like what's the hall of the place?
All right.
Like rigged them out.
Yeah.
From lethal.
I don't have that.
Like a lot of that I think probably came like that,
that character probably came from like the dark inner workings of Mel Gibson's
mind you had really is,
you would like yell like that too though.
I,
I don't have that energy.
Metro Trump kept calling Jeb Bush low energy.
I was laying on the couch going,
that's fucking me.
He's talking about it.
I'm laying on the couch and I hear about somebody dying in an avalanche and I
watch it on Tate and I laughed because I wouldn't have a fucking be dropped off
in a helicopter at the top of a mountain to go snowboarding.
Yeah.
And then they die and laugh my balls off eating a bag of chips.
Well the one person,
he's never called anybody anything is Nancy Pelosi.
And people like,
why hasn't he come up with a nickname for her yet?
Yeah.
You know,
cause you can't say content that's going to cost him the election that will cost
them 20,
27 said a joke about that.
He's like,
it's countdown until Trump tall,
thick ankle talk face.
That's what I call Hillary.
I don't even call her.
Uh,
what,
what kind of a nickname,
if you were going to help him,
like if he hired you like Nick [inaudible],
I need a solid republican comic to help me with my one liners.
What do you think?
Well,
I called her on my show.
I refer her to the,
uh,
the leathery nippled that's too wordy.
We need some pretty good luck catching her day like a lion.
Ted.
Okay.
Fuck and Naughty Nancy,
what did he call Hillary?
Crooked Hillary.
Lying Ted.
How Bout Energy Jeb?
How about a yeast infection in heels?
How about lying liberal?
Hmm.
Fuck stick.
Do you know that she's worth $100 million?
Yes,
I do.
But she figured out it's the little people jog.
She represents the working class.
You know,
she has fucking walls around our matching.
Meanwhile,
people laying their own feces in San Francisco.
Well,
that Laura Loomer chick,
the chick that,
uh,
handcuffed herself to Twitter,
she hopped Nancy's fence and he started setting up,
uh,
like uh Oh,
I agree.
Camp Nancy Slot.
Did you see that?
What happened?
What was the result?
Illegal.
She's doing something illegal.
She's trespassing.
I would say to Nancy,
I'll be outside of this fence is immoral.
MM,
right.
Build that wall or don't,
I always think the wall still,
but when we have the machine guns and tanks and flame throwers,
like I took them,
you don't have to kill.
I'm serious about this.
You're going to laugh.
Okay.
Because
you don't have to,
but seriously,
I love how we rule out lethal force as far as protecting our board.
That's not even on the plate.
So I,
okay.
It's too many of us to pick somebody off as they're climbing event,
but okay.
You something less lethal.
A supersoaker filled with cat piss
with a woman and her baby trunk come over here.
If he asked,
that's who's coming over.
It's not fucking mostly eats.
I'm one of your all males and all the women in Sheldon would have just come off
the wall.
What do you do with them?
Send them back to where the fuck that came from.
Give no a sympathy for those folks that are trying to come over here.
The ones that uh,
were,
were immigrant.
Yes.
Children.
Absolutely.
When did your parents come over?
My grandpa ramp up mine as well.
At the turn of the century,
like 1902 1,903 yup.
Fun.
They should have stayed in Italy.
You think people should have stayed in Paul?
The Irish had a,
stayed in Ireland would have no new Kapalo it will be great.
Experiment is not working.
You gotta admit this is fuck is wrong with you and watch these viral videos.
It's not,
I know you're joking around,
but I kind of seem,
I seem a little bit more dour.
Oh,
previous our previous conversations we've had,
I was faking it,
Joe.
I was faking a truck came along and I said,
I can say this,
let's take it off my chest lightened.
Cheeriness remember my bid,
I had a great bit about immigration,
how it was like having a big party,
but you had to contribute to the party.
Remember the bid on,
it's one of my albums.
The Irish brought the booze.
You Italians brought the food.
Oh,
okay.
I do remember that.
Yeah.
And the Mexican said,
fuck it.
We'll clean up.
I have to itch.
And
people loved it.
You
know,
I look,
I defend Latino's all the time on my show.
They like Italians were at the turn of the century.
Yes.
Hard working.
And when you watch the news and you see a lot of people dying,
you know,
fighting for us,
a lot of Latino names in it.
I'm a big fan.
That's not the problem.
You know,
so,
but I don't think he should be labeled a bigot.
If you believe in,
you know,
securing the borders and it's not immoral.
How about all the heroin coming over?
Is that a lie too?
I mean,
you know,
dying that over there and you pay attention to the Chapo trial.
They're bringing a little cargo ships.
Most of it's coming over and car does it.
And so if the soprano's they said an eight out of 10 cargo ships never get cha.
Yes,
that's true.
I was talking to a guy who was a longshoreman about that.
He's like,
you don't know what the fuck's in those things.
I know Annette creepy one of them was going to blow up.
That's the fuck she put.
She don't give them any I,
they already have these ideas.
They called me up and said,
that's not a bad idea.
How did you get punched?
Who,
why did that Lady Punch you?
It was a 20 year old,
uh,
bipolar girl.
Uh,
I was at levity live.
I did a show,
came offstage,
went into the green room for a few minutes and then came back out.
And I was standing to the left of the stage and I,
I don't always shake hands and do all that shit after the show.
I just don't feel it's in the job description.
Sometimes I'll do it,
sometimes they won't.
But some people started coming up to being shaken hands and taking pictures.
And this guy approaches me.
So it looked like you a little bit,
uh,
stands to my right and he goes,
can I get a picture of they go,
sure.
I stand in my right.
I'm looking at him talking to him.
He's like,
yeah,
I enjoyed the show,
but my daughter wanted a punch you in the face.
He didn't even finish the word face.
And I get suckered from this side.
Didn't even know she was in the fucking room all sudden Bam.
Whoa.
And I mean,
Bam.
I mean fucking,
you know,
I was,
I don't know if you ever get fucking suckered,
uh,
I could feel the,
I close and immediately,
you know,
and I looked right at him.
This is how good my instincts were.
Even when I was in shock,
I go,
did you just fucking set me up?
No,
it's nothing like that.
Matt.
He didn't jump in and he didn't jump in and,
and go to his daughter.
What are you doing?
And I was kinder.
I to this day,
believe it was complicit.
Uh,
he was complicit in it,
but she still pursuing it.
What did she don't she,
I finally looked at her.
I go,
why?
Why did you fucking it?
Why'd you do that?
Because you're mean she thought I was racist and sexist.
Meanwhile,
there was a table of black people,
Dominican.
It was a very diverse crowd.
Absolutely loved it.
Coming to my defense after that happened,
nobody got offended.
Even a friend of mine who see me my in time,
cause you weren't even being that political that night that she had Birkenstocks
on and you know,
bipolar and,
and,
and uh,
I'm still pursuing it.
And the guy didn't apologize.
Nothing he was,
he didn't apologize,
but he,
I said,
you just fucking said no,
I didn't man.
And it's,
it's nothing like that.
You know,
I,
she said I shouldn't have brought here,
brought her here.
But you did,
you'll weaponize your bipolar Datta is what you did.
I believe they sat down at the table before they left the house.
He knows what I did for comedy and he be,
he hated.
He didn't have the balls to do it himself.
You think?
Yeah,
that's what I look at.
You.
I'm going to work,
but
those kettle bells,
before I leave here,
I'm going to find this motherfucker.
Got To get you on a bike and get you to burn off some energy.
Jesus Christ as my rifle.
Coffee,
love dish extra and owned coffee.
It's very potent.
I want to contribute anything veteran's day.
I got some bags for you.
I'll get you some great stuff.
But yeah,
so the fucking Ike,
you had the funniest.
This is what's funny about it.
For years,
people tell me to,
you know,
keep your temper in check at Bubba by,
you'll fuck up career.
You don't Bubba,
I've been hearing that for years after this happened.
They're all gone.
Why didn't you hit her back?
Why do you,
I,
you,
you texted me like the next day or that night,
I can't remember.
And you said,
uh,
you,
it's made me laugh of five minutes.
You go,
Joe Goes,
I thought y'all was gonna be a good thing.
He didn't hit her but show cause I would have fucking leg whipped her,
which made me laugh so hard because she's his frail thing and if you like what
to you would have taken her legs Claire off like a helicopter blade.
I was belly laughing for five.
You will like a weapon.
This leg kicker.
I don't think I would have said,
okay,
well look scares me.
Well you got to um,
Kayla,
it,
someone punch you.
The real problem is like someone,
even a garage.
I saw you on the park.
You hurt your eye clip.
You in the pot.
I have a permanent dent in my face.
Yeah,
you can see it.
I have a permanent dent.
I don't,
she had a ring on.
Really?
There's a little dent there.
Yeah,
she probably had a ring on.
Yeah.
Someone could hit you in the other one down.
Joe's good for you.
That would have been embarrassing.
You,
you could lose your vision.
I mean that's 100% possible.
It happens.
People,
I had a slight concussion.
She really fucking caught me flooding.
I'm not shocked,
especially if you didn't know.
What would you have done?
I don't know.
I hope I wouldn't have done what I think I wouldn't know because you could lose
a lot of,
I know you get insurance for that and the,
the real problem is when you're not thinking,
when you get hit and then you immediately respond,
that's a real problem because look,
you've seen that video,
that giant six foot five guy who punched out 11 year old girl on the face.
She had a comment.
She,
well,
she definitely shit.
No,
I'm kidding.
Walked up to when it was with her and she definitely shouldn't have pushed him
first,
but he definitely shouldn't have punched her in the face is big giant fucking
guy.
I know with a nice shot.
You don't want,
you don't want to punch a girl.
You don't want to hit a girl and I didn't.
Don't,
you don't want to go into that reptilian part of your brain either that just
responds to being assaulted.
No,
that was killed.
That's dangerous.
I saw you that,
remember that clip years ago you were in the parking lot and the comedy store
arguing with some broad,
oh,
that feminists lady and I just mean I thought you were going to,
they're all,
I was trying to be nice to people on there.
I was nice to that lady for a long time until she's calling to tell him what
she's gonna.
She's gonna get hit me with her cigarette.
I'm like,
listen,
you're not doing anything.
I know I was watching it go.
What's going to happen next?
But it's just so stupid that people think they can get away with things like
that.
Well,
they can worldly.
It'd be if you were alone in a parking lot with their girl and she punched in
the face like that.
What if I even fucking cracker there?
What if I said that and I've been making this point.
You want true gender equality?
If we had it,
I could have fucking knocked her the fuck out and everybody went,
you know what?
She had it coming.
Yeah,
we all went home.
Well they would have been,
that's not the
world we live where you showed amazing restraint and not hitting her back
because I wasn't drinking and what,
what if you were drinking and I would've probably wrestled her at least cuffed
her and fire slap.
Yeah.
I would have gave her from behind though.
Like dirty one.
Oh,
dirty.
Yeah,
I would have came from here.
Do you ever see that?
You'll be sad video.
This is a kid,
a black kid walking down the street and some black neighbor and he's rapping
assumption shit.
And this black kid walks up behind like in a wife beater and winds up from his
ass hole with an open hand.
It would blow your brains out if you had the headphones.
But I uh,
I was proud of myself and that's why I was laughing after the incident.
People I know who've been telling me,
you know,
cool it a Weber,
you should keep it.
They were all like,
yeah,
shut off.
Fucking body slept
my arch.
Like you shut the fuck.
I was so proud of myself for once that I was,
I was the adult.
And the Rome and I,
I,
you know,
I know in the times will limiting in,
it wouldn't matter the circumstance if the toxic masculinity,
if,
if I croaked her.
Well,
I don't know man.
If somebody punches you and you punch them back,
I don't know what the fucking rules are.
I mean,
she's obviously very small.
That would've been a real problem because she's small,
but you shouldn't be fucking hitting people.
Now what you said you were working on it,
like you're still in the middle of it,
like what's going on with it?
Uh,
yes.
I uh,
pursuing it and they,
it's just so you can tell they don't give a fuck.
The Da was a woman in that county and now she's off the case.
For some reason they shuffled the,
um,
but they went,
they,
you know,
it should be a aggravated.
So,
but of course you can't go,
cause if you don't get that,
I can't sue her civilly.
If I lost that,
it would hurt my case.
At least that's the logic they would tell on me.
So they're trying to get her with like second degree harassment and now the,
there's a new woman on the case and she said they,
they're making her go to anger management and uh,
cause she has mental issues and uh,
I'm not looking for money.
I just want to make an example of her.
So,
but one,
why not pursue it as assault?
It's clearly assault.
I know.
Well you tell me.
So as your lawyers decision to not pursue it,
it's not,
no.
Nobody.
First of all,
nobody wanted to take the case because I'm fine.
Really?
Yeah.
They're like,
uh,
you sites not fucked up.
You're not in a wheelchair.
You're not.
But yeah.
Did I give the lowest credit for that much?
They are honest.
It's all about the money.
But that's crazy.
But I found the guy,
this Guy Andrew funk was a lawyer who was a marine and I said to he,
he contacted me and he put me in touch first with a Russian woman who,
who took about three of my calls and she get tired because it was no money
involved.
And he hooked me up on the ninth.
The Guy,
uh,
another lawyer who right now I'm dealing with,
but um,
yeah,
they will all right up front that if there's no money involved and you're not
permanently,
you're not going to,
you know,
but I just want,
I don't want money and this guy sort of a great meeting.
Sandra funk guys,
a marine,
he just wants to make an example.
She said I was racist and sexist,
you know.
Uh,
so I just want to make an exam.
I'm not looking for money,
but it's her father that really pisses me off.
She's nuts.
How old is just broads nuts?
Like 20,
21 goes to a school in upstate New York.
So she's not that,
not she lives on her own,
but it's the fucking old man
that was complicit in it.
I think he actually used her as,
as like a weapon that night.
It seems like it would be way harder to prove that she was,
that he was complicit in it would be to,
I agree with that.
She punched,
you know,
I agree.
But did she apologize ever?
Never.
She,
she,
she ran up into the lobby,
which is where he normally,
where you take pictures with fans and she didn't,
she,
she put her head on the table and was crying after she realized what she'd done
or whatever,
you know,
they took it or like a psychiatric hospital.
So they're saying,
well,
you know,
so I,
I just want to make an example of her.
That's all.
I,
I don't,
I'm not looking for it,
but,
but uh,
you know,
that's ridiculous.
And the next time I will hit back,
you think,
yeah,
don't know.
Wait a minute,
Joe,
you confusing me now she's too little or give me a kick that would just like
hurt her ovaries,
ovaries,
all three of them.
Go for a knee.
Go for the lead as a pussy.
Be how you damage.
I don't want to lose my knee.
I just would say don't hit her.
But
even in the future,
if somebody does know I'm not,
I would,
I would never,
well,
you've approved dabbing or prove it because you haven't done it.
You didn't do it.
You had the ultimate opportunity.
So many actually hit you.
And you didn't hit him,
but it's one of my proudest moments.
Yeah,
it should.
It should be proud of that.
I've been straight into it with a fan of is somebody in the audience know?
I've been in twice.
One time at the comedy store.
Got threw a drink at me.
Holy Shit.
And how did you restrain yourself?
Um,
I don't remember.
I essentially invited him to get killed.
How'd you do that month?
Come on up here.
I'll show you what's up and drink some asshole.
Who's him and his dad.
They were heckling everybody before the show.
Before I got on stage,
rather they were heckling everybody.
This is a long time ago.
It was probably 2003 2004 and knows who you are and he knows you're just a
pussy.
He just,
he just threw it my way,
you know,
we wanted to get famous.
Well he didn't even want to get famous.
There was no social media back then.
Not to speak of.
People aren't getting famous or things like that put in the paper.
He just a drunk asshole who interrupting comedy and the comedy store back then
had zero protection.
There was no police on the real cloud crowd room.
Right.
No crowd crowd control at all.
But yeah,
it's a fucking,
it's an issue with people,
the drinking.
Right.
And especially if you get crazy people that are drinking,
you know,
weird stuff can happen.
It's unfortunate.
Yeah.
It's just,
you know,
people that don't have respect for performers to,
they don't have respect for what you do and that it's difficult.
And if they disagree with you,
they think they are disagreeing.
Even if it's just a g you didn't even know where the joke is going.
They'll interrupt and they'll yell stuff out and they've just no,
no regard for the form that you're in.
The fact there's hundreds of other people that are there to see you.
It's about their mind and their selfish notion that they want to get out right
away and they,
and they have no idea how little it takes to throw off the balance of the room.
Oh yeah.
Just a slight confrontation.
Just see this talent.
Somebody to shut up.
And all of a sudden like,
you're the bad guy.
And a lot of times it's somebody right up front so they can hear.
Yeah.
You know,
and then it looks like it just scalding somebody for no reason.
Yeah.
I've had that though.
And I'm super sensitive.
Somebody farts in the 52nd row,
I can hear it and whatever I am,
I just have that,
you know?
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
I've learned,
I've into entire crowd.
No,
exactly.
Exactly.
I mean,
cause you,
do,
you study what's going on?
Uh,
you read their faces and whatnot and I'm really good at it.
And fucking,
if I see one person laughing out of 600 not laugh.
Yeah.
You've always been like,
no,
but I fixed it.
I fixed it years ago while after about 12 clubs said,
listen,
you've got to stop doing it.
I do,
but you know what?
I am so much better and not hitting her approved it.
I now I,
I,
uh,
I had a broad breakout that had nothing to do with me at Gotham a couple of
years ago.
What was it about two tables were fighting amongst each other.
Oh,
I heard about it was hilarious.
Talk about hitting a girl.
I just stood on the stage I love and I felt like Lenny Bruce,
who you get comics have a lot of Pumpkin us.
You know,
I had it,
but I didn't start this fucking broad breaks out.
I'm watching it.
Two tables,
girls and guys and there's a girl in the middle of their fists up like she took
three buck Tibo Class Bible classes.
She's,
and she takes a swing and hits one of the bounces.
I watch us out of the bounce and come across the room and dropped her like a
fucking use rubber.
I mean hit her like she was a guy.
Oh my God.
I don't know how this guy didn't do jail,
but these broads,
this is what this feminist movement has taken them.
Now they jump in every time you see a fight at a football game that stands is
women involvement.
Yet they really fucking think,
I'm sorry,
but legislation.
You can't fucking legislate the DNA out of us.
And uh,
they were always in the middle of it.
You notice that a lot of fucking broads think they can Duke it out now we'll do
our bunch.
Have a deletion.
But yeah,
they seem to many wonder woman movies.
Exactly.
They've been brainwashed.
Well there's a lot of people in general that think they could go around punching
people.
Like how about the all these,
uh,
Antifa dorks that are a show you face?
Well,
not only that,
they're starting fights with people and they have zero idea how to fight date.
They're swinging at people.
Did you see the one guy,
a guy swings at this guy with a bat or with a baton?
The guy catches the baton.
Eight punches him in the face and
Kaos him and his head snaps back and his head bounces off the concrete.
When he falls down.
It's awful to watch.
Like what the fuck made you think you could just hit a man with a stick?
Cause you guys disagree with each other and,
and you're right,
when they interview him after,
a lot of times they not even have to fight,
but they interviewed some of these Antifa.
They sound la almost swishy.
Yeah,
some of them swishy homosexual.
So we were saying fell that week of feminine.
Well they're,
they want to become a book.
Look,
the Antifa is just like any other group of people.
They,
they,
they give you a community,
whether it's a gang or whether it's a w w a criminal organization or what,
you know,
whatever it is,
people fall in line with the sensibilities of that organization and then you do
what you can to support that organization to show that you're a valued member.
And then,
you know,
you start wearing their fucking ski masks and hitting people with sticks and
everybody's practicing karate in the park because he thinks they're going to be
able to defend themselves.
The whole thing is ridiculous,
but because their life has no value outside of that.
Isn't it weird to do that?
Look,
my parents were hippies and when I grew up I always thought that people on the
left,
we're peace loving though.
That was what the,
the the,
the knock was there were peace,
loving,
well educated.
But you're seeing now people in the left,
like these certain factions of them.
Not all of them,
but people that are calling for violence,
they have violent pacifists.
Ironically.
Yes.
Well they don't want to do it themselves,
but they're calling you for other people to do,
right?
Yeah.
Right.
They're calling for people to get published.
Like that kid with the mag a hat,
like raise the Oslo on Ron.
Have you ever seen in more punchable face?
What the fuck are you saying?
Yeah.
You know,
it's like this extreme lack of empathy for young people to like young people
that,
that don't fall in line with their ideas.
They don't give a fuck,
fuck that kid punched him,
throw him in jail,
lock them up.
It's just like,
it's,
there's a lack of empathy and a lack of thought behind it.
It's,
it's very,
in social media is only throwing gas on that.
Yes.
And then you got these Russian accounts that are firing this up on both sides
that are attacking from the left and the right.
I think that's a way bigger issue than people think.
I think these,
these troll farms and these people that are setting up these fake accounts and
just getting people dialed up.
I think there's a lot of fucking lemmings out there and a lot of people just,
they fall into these arguments like how many people do you know that getting
involved in Twitter arguments and then they,
they,
they stew with those arguments all day.
They keep checking their mentions.
They get heavily involved with that.
If someone can get you involved in that,
like if the Russians can get a group of dummies involved in that kind of
dispute,
they could literally change the way people are interacting.
We chat with each other,
they're making the interactions more aggressive,
more violent.
So you think it's the Russian?
I think it has something to do with it.
I think there's a polarization between the left and the right period.
But I think they are definitely a class.
Yeah.
This,
this thing that I was reading or that listening to rather this Sam Harris'
podcast,
very fucking,
because they're,
they're talking
about the,
what we actually know about the data and where it's coming from and who,
how these people are doing this and how they're setting these things up.
Yeah.
That guy,
the comic that you and I talked about
again,
that clip of this Russian who was a former KGB guy who defected to this country
explaining how it works on back in the 80s yeah.
Explaining exactly how it works and what he was saying.
This is 30 something years ago.
35 years is going down.
Exactly the way he explained it,
and Putin is a Cajun Navy guy.
Oh,
Christ shit.
Yeah.
That's this idea that Trump's working with them as fucking silly.
Well,
I don't know about that.
I don't think he's working with them to undermine democracy,
but I definitely think they've got some business dealings.
I mean,
they were offering him to Trump.
That's not illegal.
The penthouse in Trump tower and illegal,
none of that is illegal.
Don't take that from me.
Take that from Alan Dershowitz.
Don't smarter than both of us.
I'm not saying it's illegal,
but I don't think that he was honest about that.
He said,
I don't do any dealings with Russia.
I don't have any business with Russia.
And he definitely did.
That's just not true.
Well,
we'll see.
We'll see.
That's what the targeting,
they're not going to get them a perennial.
You don't think so?
You think he's going to just,
Oh,
maybe impeachment,
but I'd even on,
on what k?
I don't even know what they'd get them.
High crimes and misdemeanors.
I don't,
I don't know what he's done to talk about building a tower in Moscow is not
illegal to have business and what he,
what did he lie about specifically?
Well,
there's a lot like what?
We could pull it up.
Let's,
let's find out all the things.
What are you?
Get a of salon.com or you can go to a million different websites.
Well,
I know we,
we just establish at the,
the fucking social media tilts lapse.
So yes,
social media does.
We're not talking about pulling up social media page.
What are you pulling up?
I don't know.
Actually,
she ain't gonna let me go.
I'm like,
I'm not a Trump scholar and haven't have at my disposal all the different times
that he'd lied.
But it's a lot.
So what do you think's going to happen to him?
You think he'll impeach him you mean?
No,
no.
He'll resign or what?
I don't know.
Look,
I'm not,
I'm not claiming to be any sort of an expert in legal proceedings.
I have no idea either.
That's why I quoted Dershowitz.
Yeah,
I think,
well isn't Hersh was working with Trump now Giuliani is,
oh that's right.
Dershowitz.
I always got a Dershowitz cause he's trucking Lib.
Trump average 15 and accuracies and ms truce a day 2018 almost triple the rate
from a year of hell.
Kay.
But hold on a second.
What's the demand?
They're season myths.
Truths.
It's a European paper.
But isn't that a little odd?
15 a day?
Cause I don't know is making that claim.
I don't know the exact year.
15 and accuracies.
You doubt that it's true.
You think that's all lie that just made up the fact that he lies a lot?
Uh,
lies about what?
First of all,
it's a definition of a lie.
I don't know.
Let's see.
It says Washington Post's who they hate those.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Say the president made 1,989 such claims in 2018 by the last day of 2018 in the
Washington does 17.
That's my point.
But what,
but let's wait and see what it says.
I mean they can't lie.
The total figures
isn't to 7,600.
So you think they just made up all these lives?
Not all of them,
I'm sure.
But you could,
you could go back with Hillary and fucking count.
You could go to uh,
go to Fox News and then put all that,
pull up an article.
How many times Hillary was inaccurate.
Do you know what a,
what about Islam is?
Uh,
what about him?
Yeah,
when someone talks about something and instead of refuting it with facts,
he go,
yeah.
Well what about Hillary?
What about bill?
Bill did a two.
What about this?
What about that?
You're going to sound,
what about Islam?
And that's what I just committed.
I was or one cause you were saying that Hillary lied,
but you both agree,
but you're making my point.
You're going into Washington pouch.
That's just Jamie pulled up the independent.
We could go,
we could go anywhere,
but hold on a second.
Yeah,
I'm with you.
I think Hillary is a liar.
I think she deleted 30,000 emails.
I think it's criminal.
I think the Clinton Foundation's,
uh,
a fucking fully illegal organization.
I think they rigged the DNC.
I think they,
they,
they rigged the primaries against Bernie.
I'm with you.
I'm not a supporter now I'm not saying you,
I,
but when's the last time somebody made a statement like that and said this many
inaccuracies when Bill Clinton was in office?
Hillary,
I'm sure,
I'm sure there was some inaccuracies,
but first of all,
when Bill Clinton was in office,
they weren't,
they count Obama's,
I don't know.
But that's what about Islam?
You know what I'm saying?
We're just talking about Trump.
You were saying that Trump doesn't lie and they're saying the lies.
I'm not saying he doesn't.
First of all,
he said,
what does he like?
No.
First of all,
you know,
I like to know the definition of a lie.
If he misstates something,
do you think it does it accidentally?
I'm sure sometimes when you talking that Mckay,
so if he's lies 1,900 time,
give me an example of a blatant.
Yeah,
that's fucking,
it's Washington Post.
It's horse shit.
I don't know I do you think
he said?
No,
he's a bullshitter.
For sure.
Joe,
would you argue that they haven't been trying to take him down since he came
down that fucking escalator?
How about the deep state?
How about,
how about the fucking dossier?
What?
Why is anybody know?
What does that mean?
The dossier.
What dossier?
The fake Das.
She had Christopher Steele that they use to get the,
the the Pfizer.
What you're talking about.
I just stand.
They know what I'm talking about.
No,
no,
no they don't.
They don't cause I don't know.
What do you mean the dossier defect?
Josh matted.
They said they know what he's talking about.
They had,
yes,
they had.
You have to all this.
So you're being willfully ignorant.
Oh,
I don't know the Dick.
I don't know.
Hey,
I'm,
I'm explaining.
Hold on a second.
I've heard these are terms I've heard.
Yes.
And it's stuff,
but you don't know the full extent of this.
He had the oldest is what I'm talking about.
This is as big a story is anything Trump has done.
What is the story?
The Steele dossier that a Hillary used,
they went to,
you had to get a application to as a coach and they went,
they used a DNC opposites.
Christopher Steele,
who's a British guy,
had connections in Russia.
Remember when they said Trump was at a hotel and watching girls peeing on each
other?
That was all in the Steele dossier.
Christopher Steele is his name.
They use that in their application to get a Pfizer warrant to spy on Trump
during his campaign.
That's fact.
That's not me being a right winger.
That is fact.
Okay,
so,
but the fact that that like that you don't know that.
No,
I remember that now.
Oh,
that,
that's what I'm talking about.
When you were doing a story as Trump,
you know,
lying about the number of paper does inauguration.
I want to know the,
I want to know a live from Trump that's a equal,
equal in power as like when Obama said,
you know a lot about healthcare that you could keep your health care and all
that.
Give me an example of Trump.
Would that big of a lie?
Well,
listen,
I told you I'm not,
it's a lie.
I'm not saying it's as on president slide.
All politicians lie.
I'm just saying they start to count it.
When Trump took over,
they started keeping,
you know,
we'll be keeping statistics.
Like what?
Give me an example.
Like,
look,
we just showed you all the numbers of the Washington Post.
So if I give you another example,
you're going to say,
Oh,
if you go to a salon,
salon.com,
all right,
we'll go,
go to ou.
I don't know what you've gotten more done than any other administration.
Okay,
this is a lie.
So true,
blah,
blah.
See now,
so if somebody says it's a lie,
let's see what it says.
Jamie,
go back to it.
What are you doing?
But who's saying that's a lie?
Let's see.
Let's see what it says.
Jesus Christ.
You're so defensive.
It's like to work for the organization.
Now.
I don't,
but you're putting you,
I'm saying you're using the Washington Post.
This isn't the Washington.
Well,
what is it?
Oh,
the NBC.
Okay.
NBC.
Okay,
so,
and one is that,
look,
man,
I'm just reading what's in front of me.
I know.
And I'm just,
you're so emotional about this is ridiculous.
Four cups of coffee and Michelle had too,
Huh?
Oh,
please let me know.
I'm right.
I don't know your media tour.
We're talking to you.
Tell me you don't know that the mainstream media hates Trump.
They do.
I do.
Why would you put your fucking,
because I want to know whether or not they are saying,
but what is fat?
Stop.
Stop doing that.
Jamie.
Go back to where it was.
You can't go.
Says Trump later said that he intended the UN moment to garner a laugh that is
repeated this claim.
Seriously since.
Okay,
so he says that's my,
my administration has accomplished more than almost any administration in the
history of the country.
So this is just,
that's an expense.
That's hyperbole.
Right,
and people were laughing when he said that and so he was saying that he meant to
say it as a laugh.
There are hiring measures of success,
but it's not true that his administration has been more successful than any
other administration in history when it comes to legislation.
Trump aside,
plenty of bills in his first two years of President Barack Obama in his first
two years has significantly more science,
significantly more.
Okay.
This is just one thing.
I mean I'm sure there's many,
many other things that you can keep going over and over again.
I'm with you.
I'm not saying I'm not a bullshitter,
but I'm just saying all of a sudden they keep score when it,
when tried,
he's no more from my end that he keeps score because he lied so much.
Keep the who is keeping score and fucking Hillary was secretary of state.
Well it's the same secretary
of state and I don't know how much she lied as opposed to how much he realize
you're a lot bigger.
There's about her fucking server and about the Steele dossier that that is huge.
That is getting under cupboard like nobody's been that,
that dwarfs Watergate when they amass General Flynn that,
that,
that dwarfs Watergate.
Hmm.
That's an interesting conversation.
I don't know if that's the truth.
I don't know enough about Watergate,
but in an Ohio for about that either.
Okay.
Is it the coffee going on here?
Well,
yeah.
Why was in strung out?
Could we queen?
What do you want?
Freedom and emotional.
Not Emotional.
It's just I'm just you,
but you're acting as if I'm against you and I'm not against me.
Even if you were,
they'll be fine,
but yet I'm not,
you're not against me,
but I'm just saying to call Trump a big ally than the fucking,
every other politician is an exaggeration.
I don't know.
By the mainstream media who hates his guts.
I think most politicians are liars.
I think that just a lowly costume to doing that.
But I think the way he lies is unusual.
I think it's the usual.
It's just that unusual.
You don't think so.
He,
he exaggerates like statements like that because an exaggeration,
although he did do a lot in its first couple of years,
would never get credit for it.
You know,
unless you watched Fox knows you're not going to.
But um,
would you agree that as you get older you become more like more conservative?
No,
I was always a bit of a Dick.
I got a tattoo of mixing in my house.
Say I thought it was fun.
No,
I would say that was,
that's a fee.
What do they say about if you're young,
you're young and conservative,
you have no soul,
no heart and you're old and liberal.
Brilliance to mind.
Something like that.
Yeah.
I would say,
yeah,
that's true.
But I could always detect the bullshit,
you know?
I mean,
I remember watching CNN in an airport and I first started comedy and it's like
1988 nine,
you know,
and getting excited at some of the shit.
Well,
it's interesting because,
uh,
I don't disagree with you on everything and I love you as a person.
You're a great guy.
I liked you a lot.
Always happy to see you.
But yet you and I here get a little heated and talking about this stuff,
but this is politics.
This is how divisive politics are.
If even a person like penny would never,
I would never fucking,
I would never leave here going,
I don't want to do that show again.
I have known each other.
We've known each other for 30 years.
That's not the problem.
What I'm saying is I'm just using it as example of how divisive politics.
Absolutely.
When people talk to him about it,
no,
I mean a lot of people are,
right?
Yes.
Yeah.
I,
I'm not afraid of it.
A lot of people are fade a bad vibes and bad feelings and this is one of the
days,
but this is one of the things that makes people tow the line,
right?
It's the fear of this kind of altercation,
the fear of this kind of like you don't want that from inside your party,
so you,
you start using they and them,
you start thinking that everyone should be able to use any bathroom that they
feel like they identify with.
You start,
you start going along the line.
It's one of the more interesting things about politics is that if you tell me
that you're Republican,
I can kind of guess your stance on God.
I can kind of guess your stance on being pro life pro choice,
second amendment rights.
It's like all those things sort of fall in line and it's very interesting.
It's very interesting how you,
you sort of adopt,
uh,
not you,
but people sort of adopt a whole group of things when you decide you're
Republican,
you decide you're a democrat.
I don't,
but yeah,
I don't think I fall into that.
Um,
how do you feel about guns?
Am what got any guns?
I'm going to get one.
Just one.
Yeah.
I,
I'm not a big gun guy.
Uh,
as far as a boy,
Shannon,
uh,
um,
I don't want to say pro choice,
but I'm not,
I'm not pro life.
One of the big reasons is if you,
like,
I got a dad is dying of Alzheimer's,
watching them.
It's the saddest thing.
If I could kill him tomorrow,
put them out of his misery,
I would,
I think you could take him to Oregon.
The states that allow that there are states,
um,
that uh,
allow people to,
um,
I think,
can I go over state lines with them?
Is it like taking a girl of a stale?
No,
there was a girl who was dying of cancer who,
uh,
went to Oregon for that very reason.
Yeah.
They're um,
Oregon is one of those,
I want to say,
I might be saying it wrong,
but I think the idea is a right to a dignified death.
No,
you're right.
Just read about.
Yeah.
Um,
look man.
The idea that you're supposed to just keep staying alive until your fucking
heart stops beating when silly,
horrible pain and it's,
it's,
it's evil.
You don't do it too.
I had to put my dog down.
Okay.
I love this dog.
I've had him for 13 years and I had to put him down because he couldn't walk
anymore.
Do you do chuck them out?
And I brought him to a place.
They actually came to my house actually and they put them down.
Sad Shit.
But,
but you can't do that for a 98 year old man who's falling apart.
You have to let him eventually stop breathing.
Right.
You know,
which is sad.
All the rights should go out the window.
That should be your first,
right.
It's your God damn life.
Yeah.
So that's why I couldn't be like pro choice pro in all pro life or whenever.
Uh,
and that,
and I got girls pregnant and I was younger and I was glad there was a planned
parenthood or whatever it was.
You know the guy in the alley with a stick.
I
think his name was Dave long as you answer.
I don't buy w w in show Biz Joe,
Eh,
you know it is in Showbiz cause this is a pretty liberal business.
If you are like,
if you're a right on to have 10 issues,
you're like a fucking Nazi,
you know.
I mean I get called alt right adjacent.
It's my favorite.
Oh my God.
They keep coming up with,
well you can't call me all right because I'm pretty left wing.
I'm mostly,
they call it so they call me outright adjacent probably because I have people
like you on now.
I'm going to be more outright adjacent cause you cause you isn't that silly.
You have me on to,
you know,
your listeners probably,
like you'll
like listen to this guy.
I don't agree with anything that should be a feather in your cap.
And they're gonna hold that against you.
Yeah.
Silly.
Well,
you know,
to the,
it's not rational,
but again,
it's people trying to have an effect on you.
They're trying to have an effect.
They're trying to make some ways try and do something.
The writing blogs or creating videos while they're doing it to try to put
pressure on you.
It's interesting though.
It's weird.
It's weird from a psychological perspective.
You're looking at it from the outside.
You know,
it's,
uh,
it's disconcerting when it's happening to you,
but when you step back and look at it like,
it's interesting.
It's like the systems are opposing each other and they're trying to figure out
where the weaknesses are and how to,
how to push to affect the other side.
Yeah.
And it's not,
and it's not just left.
Right.
You know,
it's bigger than that.
So,
you know,
what was the book I read?
Um,
what's the place where they go to meet every year?
Bohemian Grove,
the group build the bird grope.
That was one of my favorite books.
The truth about the Bilderberg group and um,
what goes on there and the powerful people that meet and uh,
people,
I was saying it's probably 10 guys in a room that run the whole fucking well,
okay.
But you show me them until then I'll stay in the left.
Right.
Fight and have fun.
The idea is that there's 10 guys to control everything and they don't give a
fuck if it's left or right.
They're just about money.
It's,
yeah.
But led the round house fellows were involved and,
and they,
but it's weird.
That was really creep.
They plan shit out decades ahead.
And did they plan out education?
Yeah.
Decades ahead though.
And,
and it comes true like they write a sitcoms script at that lasts for 15 years.
W with plot points.
It was,
that buck was incredible.
I can't remember the author's name,
but um,
yeah,
but I don't,
I don't,
I don't mind.
I used to sit at that table at the comedy cellar.
That's how tough crowd came about.
Me and Patrice yelling at each other about Rachel's Shit.
Tough crowd was a great fucking show.
But I really am worried that you couldn't have a show like die.
No,
you should be.
Now let me ask you,
and I'm not taking left,
right,
but who would be to blame for that?
That that's why I lean.
Right.
And I think,
and you do in some areas,
you're in a,
I mean,
you're an artist.
You're a stand up.
I cannot be,
I cannot vote with a party that is 4 cents a share.
And,
and for group things.
Did we ever find out what's going on with Dennis Prager?
Did we get a line on that?
Because that's still bothering you.
No,
no.
I just,
I,
it does bother me because I liked the guy.
He's great.
He's,
I don't agree with him on a lot of things,
but he seems like a very nice guy.
And I like Adam.
I do tow both those guys.
It,
there's a lawsuit,
he's bringing a lawsuit that,
uh,
they think it's going to go a long way.
There's,
cause they were labeling his show is hate speech.
Maybe it's back up or whatever.
But I know that story,
you can find that anywhere.
There's a real concern that the ideologies behind these tech companies all go in
direction and
they have the overwhelming control of the narrative because of the fact that
they're all,
what we're,
we're,
we're getting all of our information.
Most people are getting it on their phones.
Most people are getting a lot of their media on their phones.
The Netflix said something like 50% of the people that watch my special watch it
on a phone.
That's amazing.
I mean,
that's crazy that people are,
so all of this stuff is coming from these tech companies.
Doesn't have then that kind of bother you that it's the phone.
Because when I hear that,
not that it matters of my specials,
but um,
uh,
when I picked somebody's watching something and I've found you don't have their
full attention,
they're doing other things.
Yeah.
I mean as opposed to sitting in front of their computer or TV.
That kind of bug you.
You put all that work into it and they're,
they're on the subway watching it and the,
I don't pay attention to when I can control.
I don't that to make me nuts.
Yeah,
I got to get over there.
That's where the Muslims,
I love it.
I'm going to have to try the little one.
I'll give you a little one.
Just that one step a day.
I get to drive to San Diego.
I was perfect.
Me and traffic.
Well,
what time is your show?
I know I'm fucking going to be times you show at seven 30 it's full.
I,
I pulled up on ways that says if I leave at three it's going to take four hours.
Oh,
you better leave it to then it's almost kicked me out of
the coffee,
but then I just drove there last week for Brendan shops.
Specially tee shot a showtime special.
How long did,
it took me five and a half hours to get down there.
It took me fucking ever flying.
I didn't want to.
I was in bringing up before the show.
I thought I saw you got to show there tonight.
My managers,
my manager.
Yeah.
My man,
his thought he's doing me a favor.
Just pull it up in Google.
Just go all the way now.
Yeah,
we'll Google do it too.
If you just Google a Wicca.
Where's the Gig?
Where yet?
A comedy palace.
Eight ladies.
Don't punch him.
Now.
You know where he is.
Don't show up and day.
You're going to throw that fucker.
You're racist piece of shit.
You fucking sexist.
You hate women feminists.
Oh it is.
It's a fucking,
it's a Udall uterine cancer.
Females of the future.
The future's feminine.
I'll take my life tonight.
That's
filthy horse anyways to fucking Harry thick ankle girls that can't get laid and
they turn their Angus.
Some of them is pretty,
they just haven't met a stripper who's a feminist yet.
Oh Wow.
And I've talked to almost to have in the last 40 years,
three 45 right now.
Three hours and 43 hours and 45 minutes.
Okay.
If you leave right now,
you get there an hour before the show.
You kicking me out.
I think don't make me come across what I'm nervous about and I'm just being
honest,
but when I'm nervous about is that it's gonna get worse seemingly longer in the
next hour.
Do you understand?
It's making me nervous that you are nervous because I was the one who's going
to,
I'm going to have to get out of here a little early.
I thought you've got to go.
You'll be fine.
You'll fucking good dude.
I got down to San Diego on Saturday night.
I was delirious.
I had been smoking and fucking
it's the fumes from the highway cause everything was stop and go the whole way
that might want to try to catch a flight if you can.
The only thing that saved me was gone to the fucking airport.
We're under the Washer that yet.
I would rather walk.
Run the jewels is the only thing that saved me.
He's rocking out my car.
It was a,
it was a horrible drive.
Yeah.
Well the whole world lives here.
Of course it's going to be horrible.
No.
The real Americans live in the middle tone thing.
Jesus land.
Yeah.
The fly over states live in Ohio.
What do you like to work?
Where's your favorite place to perform?
That's where I'm going to get you.
San Francisco.
I love San Francisco.
I'm kidding.
I haven't been there in years.
They loved me when I was in the cockpit because they didn't look happy that
someone's like bucking the trends.
Right?
Well that's how it used to be,
but that's how left wing and then fucking stupid dip.
Turn it to Bobby Slayton could've run for mayor of San Francisco,
right?
Yeah.
Does he still play up there?
I have not seen.
They loved me.
I almost won that competition.
They have me at the punchline twice a year for like three years.
I love the punchline and then all of a sudden,
you know,
and I'll go,
no,
but I don't.
Uh,
what's tough,
people always say they,
I bet you you killed down south and Atlanta.
No,
those people are,
they all have guilt complexes about being racist and bigots.
So when you do something off color,
they like,
they'll laugh and under their cowboy hats.
What about like Cleveland?
Cleveland's a top one for me.
They don't have the,
like I,
I they don't have like,
I don't know.
My sarcasm is almost too too,
they're almost to Midwest for me.
You know what I mean?
Honest to God really have about Columbus.
I don't do a Columbus.
Why don't you do Columbus?
I don't know.
Artie Lange got in trouble for fucking doing black jokes there.
I don't do black jokes.
I'm just saying,
I don't know.
So I e land got in trouble.
This,
you're like,
oh scratch that danger.
Lack prob by black bounce a complaint because he did a black joke and Michael,
that sounds like a great club.
Yeah.
Which club is this?
The funny bone.
Yeah.
That's a great fucking club.
I know.
I'll get there.
Get over there.
I will go.
I'll get there.
No,
cause it's changed a lot since um,
I just said,
because I thought I want to do small theaters,
Joe,
I don't want to do clubs.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm doing this to cover the cost to come on out here tonight and I'm doing
Ventura Harbor Comedy Club Cause I,
oh,
that's a good spot.
It's fun.
That Chinese restaurant,
hold on.
What's an actual club upstairs?
Yeah,
it's a Chinese restaurant.
It is not.
It's a comedy club.
I worked at,
what do you mean Chinese restaurants and it's connected to a Chinese Chinese
food there.
Oh,
it's connected to a rent.
It's still not make it sound like I'm standing in the kitchen.
I've worked there.
Cheap books coming up the fuck.
It's a good spot.
I love it.
So I'm doing that Sunday.
I'm not scared to wear to a Chinese restaurant.
Is this coming up?
This is the dream.
Live comedy panel.
And come see you.
I'm counting on it cause I did not JDL polishing their knuckles right now.
Good.
I'm fucking,
I have two knives in my car.
Can I bring that Samurai thing?
Can I bring that 1500 year old school?
I want to give you some sort of protection.
I don't want to give you a weapon.
Please.
I can do 12 deep knee bends.
Nobody's gonna fuck with me out.
Um,
what about for 57?
I'm hanging you.
I'm hanging in there,
especially for no hormone replacement.
I tried to get you on the sauce.
You don't think that's my first call?
Me?
Yeah.
I'll look you up again.
Get you to the doctor.
They'll take care of you.
Figuring out what your blood levels are at kitchen on the right vitamins.
Doctor in New York,
right?
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah.
There's a lot near you can to get you off of these though.
Get John to these,
but he got the marijuana.
Yeah,
I know.
I heard it at the marijuana.
It doesn't help you go to sleep or something.
Aren't you one of those guys now?
I can't help.
Remember I took a,
I took one eighth edible.
It was like doing acid for me.
I was watching Bob Newhart and all of sudden I was in this,
in this fucking show and it was in black and wife and my wife was not my wife
and my house was not my house.
I get all this stuff.
This is from a little bit of an edible.
Those are strong.
They're making them,
they're making them strong.
They're doing horrible things to people out here.
But now they have new rules where each edible has to be 10 milligrams,
which is doable.
But here's the thing,
ain't nobody measuring those fucking things.
How about the CBD Shit?
Joe Cbd is Great.
I know.
I,
I went into a bar in New York and the bath and it pushed it on me.
They were like,
he had like a campaign gone.
And uh,
the problem was I had already had a couple drinks so I couldn't tell,
but I slept good when I took it.
Yeah.
CBD is amazing.
Some of it has a little bit of [inaudible],
but it's very little.
Most of it is very little,
but it's really good for your joints and for aches and pains,
inflammation and stuff like that.
For a lot of people,
it's good for anxiety,
you know,
I don't have any of that.
Seems cool as a cucumber.
Wow.
Amazing cigarettes.
Amazing.
That's what keeps me cool.
What about Texas?
Do you like work at Texas?
Yes,
I be,
I gotta be honest.
I haven't been in a do these places in a while,
but yes.
Uh,
and I'll go to Texas.
No,
I did.
I was just,
I wasn't Dallas and some of the jokes that make people cringe elsewhere.
We're getting rounds of applause
in Dallas.
Anytime I said Joe just,
you know,
not in a hateful way.
It might fuck tonight,
but you know,
you say Jew and it's nice.
Say it in a way.
It sounds hateful that south,
that's where [inaudible] does a bit about that.
And I owe you,
I used to ask Louis when we lived together,
I go,
how can we first moved to New York?
I said,
I hear people saying,
yeah,
he's a Joe or whatever and nobody gets mad and stuff because in Boston if
somebody said he had back in jail,
uh,
but um,
but Dallas was great for me.
So Dallas is great.
Houston Houston's great.
Austin's great.
Texas is the shit you used to.
And I did an album in Houston.
Did you do it at the last fac laugh stop in river oaks?
Yes.
I did an album that more.
Nah,
Dan not,
that was well that was,
yeah.
What is it now?
Um,
sometimes like they'll have shows.
There's sometimes,
I think someone had something there for awhile.
I don't know the full story,
but that was one of the greatest clubs ever laugh.
Stop in river oaks.
Remember that crazy dude was running at the fuck's his name?
Yeah.
Fuck's his name?
Bald guy?
Yes.
Mark.
Yeah.
Last name.
Oddly enough.
Joey knew him.
Wheelwell real well.
I forgot about that.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yes.
And that was bill Hicks.
Yeah.
Place Day.
Had a fucking legit open,
moping in the fucking end.
The front.
And it was legit.
Dude comics.
I watched it.
I got these kids are open.
They were Euston,
right?
Yup.
Houston is a very eclectic city.
It's really different.
It's not what people think of when they take a Houston that take a cowboy hats
and old.
No,
it's not.
It's very diverse.
There's a lot going.
It was a very urban,
there's a lot of cool shit going on in Houston.
Very artistic.
I'm a big fan.
Yeah.
Same with like,
you know,
people always call,
you must kill an Atlantic.
And I'm like,
no,
they,
they're,
they're PC.
They're act cosmopolitan areas for the most part.
Yeah.
You don't kill in Atlanta.
I kill if I want to,
but some of the shit that you thought,
but some of the stuff you think would kill,
you know,
they'd get to,
it's like,
eh,
even for us down here.
Right.
But that,
you know,
cosmopolitan areas is more a,
what about Phoenix?
Phoenix is a,
gets Phoenix is good.
That's a great,
yeah.
Yeah.
There's a few great spots.
If you didn't live in New York,
where would you live for comedy purposes?
It just to life in comedy for life and comedy.
Yeah.
Burlington,
Vermont.
Really?
No,
I'm kidding.
If I could be up there with fucking Ben and Jerry.
No,
I would Bernie's dealer night boy.
But it has to involve comedy.
Probably Texas.
Really?
Yeah.
Somewhere.
Did.
My brother lived outside of Dallas and he loved it.
That's great.
Um,
do you have money?
You could have seven castles.
Oo,
seven.
I don't want seven too many to look after folks.
You should see the place where any doing Joe show.
Yeah.
The Gym outside a nice gym.
Uh,
I like Texas.
I'm a big fan of Texas.
I would live in Texas.
I think I'd live in Colorado first though.
Yeah.
We'd not just weed mountains.
You like them?
I love the way what it does for you.
There's something about being around mountains said,
uh,
um,
I was actually reading something about this.
There's an actual thing that happens to people when you're faced with immense
natural beauty that it diminishes your ego and yourself and it puts people in,
you know,
put you in a hang glider or show perspective being being around mountains.
It's a humbling.
Sure.
You're around them.
It's as beautiful.
It's like the best looking art you could ever see.
He's like a gorgeous mountain with some green hills and the sun coming out of
the,
it's like,
well that's good.
Good to look at it as anything that's ever existed.
I'm not very religious.
I don't know.
I haven't made up my mind,
but when I see stuff like that is when I get kind of,
do you want to make it be mine?
I got something right here for you.
What does that mushrooms.
Mushrooms.
I know exactly what before Bro.
Wake up your mind about Joe.
If I commanded by Tuck days on the,
did he show before?
Just take a little one like no,
fuck that.
Nobody's got to get hurt.
Just a little one.
Jamie,
do you do that?
Just a little one.
I don't want to,
I don't want to be giggling in the car on the way down.
Throwing up on myself.
It'll be fine.
What's it though?
What's going to happen?
I want to get out of here before it takes effect and I was going to get me in a
fucking some type of scissors.
Law should be legal.
I suppose it would make people mellow the fuck out,
right?
Would open that third eye man who would do something really good for people.
The problem is you forget you take it.
Sometimes you're like an hour and a half later like why am I so,
oh,
okay.
Yeah.
I don't want to be that far.
My own head.
That's scary.
Have you ever done the float tank?
No.
You want to do that?
Why can't I get up?
Float the fuck the egg.
I should go down there on the raft like everybody else does.
Last time I ran into you,
I am so nervous that you get nervous about me making my show.
Do you understand?
I think we're going to get you out of here in about 15 minutes.
That's what I think.
Is that all right?
Yeah.
I think that's the right move.
Maybe 10 you guys got to be really fucking nervous.
I wish I was,
but at least you have ways,
ways to put you on some weird fucking flunky back country routes.
It'll cut 20 minutes out of it and end up in Mexico.
You'll be fine.
Very close to Mexico,
but super conservative.
That's what's interesting about San Diego.
I used to,
I don't want my first album.
I didn't.
La Jolla military.
Yes.
It's all minutes early on there.
Yeah.
Safe as fuck.
Maybe I'll have one of those guys at my show tonight.
The people have said to me like,
where?
Where would you live?
Would you live in a military town?
Like,
yes.
That's what show used to live.
You got to have gyms for sure.
He definitely gonna have a gun ranges.
When you say that,
does that when they throw you into the alt right adjacent category?
Um,
probably,
yeah.
I mean the American flag behind me probably contributes to that.
Oh my God.
How horrible.
I know you're fucking extremist job.
The constitution,
decolonizing.
That's one of my favorite things.
Decolonizing or you've been paying attention to that expression.
People want to decolonize certain,
certain things.
Like what?
Oh look,
hairstyles and shit.
Tee colonize a Hashtag.
You're not yet.
There was a guy who got kicked off of a show these similarities talking to rent
it out.
No,
there's a guy who got kicked off of a show.
He was,
um,
he was on a show,
a,
I think it was in Montreal,
and he had a,
he had dreadlocks on and it was this,
he's apparently gender fluid,
which I guess I dabbled in that.
Yeah,
you can go back and forth.
She can beat a man and a woman.
But he does have dreadlocks and they kicked him off the show because he's a
white guy with dreadlocks and he defended their position.
Uh,
and one of the phrases they use was about decolonizing specific a hairstyles and
taking them away from white people and giving them back to the people that,
oh,
that's sort
of appropriation is what their acute cultural procreation hairstyles.
I'd like to go a dreads has a 57 year old.
One time you'd be weird.
It'll be where with treads.
I get famous just from that then that in a white goatee
colloquy and says I should wear a black.
He says,
I'm going to Turtle Agri Steve Jobs in a black turtleneck with yellow lightning
bolts and call myself dawn Corrado.
Why?
Why does he just be in funny?
I heard he has an amazing new show.
That guy his shit.
Watch him work it out,
man.
It's a,
it's all about politics.
It's about what we were talking to him about.
Red versus bled.
So timely and shit and you know,
um,
he's a,
he's a craftsman.
I watch him.
I had a fat black pussy cat.
I'd go on sometimes I have a show up to his,
what is the fat black pussy gets?
You'd fucking love it.
Just right around the corner from the comedy cellar.
He's got a real Bohemian failed to it.
People sitting in couches,
there's lamps.
It holds about 75 people call was of course quick enough and smart enough to say
I'm using this every night to work shit out.
And people know you can say like,
I'm only charging you $5 because I'm going to be working in new stuff out.
But you would love it.
I just kind of Bohemian feel to it and um,
it's,
and they give you the door.
Not that that effect has anything to do with you,
but um,
but it's great.
It's a,
it's a,
you know,
you do an hour of yarn.
I smoke.
Wow time.
Um,
it's so fun.
It's so,
uh,
again it's like 75 seats has a little activity to do,
to help.
That was very attractive.
So New York has some weird little clubs.
Man.
It's really interesting how New York has it because guys are just hopping around
like that.
I never,
when I lived in New York,
I could never afford to live in the city.
So I lived in new Rochelle and when I did gigs,
I was like,
well,
I could work in town and do 10 minutes or 15 minutes or I could just go on the
road and do a Gig in Connecticut or do a Gig and Jersey and make actual money.
And so I always did that.
So even when I lived in New York or hardly ever worked in New York,
yeah,
I don't as much anymore.
I used to,
you know,
I used to go to the comedy cellar every night,
but Louis made that place world famous and it's not,
it used to be a room where you could work shit out,
take your time.
But now it's,
you know,
it's a fucking tourist.
It's packed.
It's still a great club.
And I,
but I feel like yell grow that I don't want to do.
I don't want to go on stage unless I'm doing at least 40 minutes,
you know what I mean?
I got to get something done.
Uh,
if 15 minutes sets don't,
that's why I still the fat black pussy get,
which is such a great thing.
Um,
so look at that.
Nice.
Yeah,
that's it.
Nice.
That looks big.
And I would always looks bigger from a picture.
It's tiny.
That's what like from a bed that's from the balcony up there,
which is like the,
uh,
the belly room with the store.
It's small.
Smaller than that.
Really?
Oh yeah.
Wastewater that he's smaller than that.
The stores,
70 people upstairs.
So it's the same
all the way.
The one way a belly.
Yeah.
Little,
not the original.
Original.
Yeah,
I would say like that.
Yeah.
It,
it,
it's,
you'd fucking love it.
And people sitting in couches and shit.
Wow.
It's,
it's really cool.
And,
and Noam who runs the,
he couldn't be nicer,
you know,
and uh,
that's the only one I really do in the city.
Really.
Yeah.
I'm like,
you,
I'd rather go to governor's or,
or somewhere else and do some real time governance.
A great club.
Yeah.
The other thing about,
um,
doing,
like clubs where there's a lot of people on where you only do in 15 minutes.
The good thing about it is that it's not your crowd,
so you have to make people laugh.
They're there just to see comedy.
They're not just see nick DiPaolo.
Right.
Like if you go to,
you know how that happens to some guys,
they develop their crowd and then they kind of lose their edge.
Yes.
Fucking it's scary,
right?
Yes.
Last time I saw you onstage,
I walked into Caroline's,
uh,
I was just,
I was just in town for something and you were on stage.
It was a late show and you were doing some fucking show about Katrina,
a joke about Katrina that they spelled help wrong on the roof where they were.
Yeah.
How many people die because they couldn't spell help.
Can I look into it from a helicopter?
It says,
yeah.
I said,
if you want have just stepped in that water,
you're standing.
No,
I was fucking crying laughing.
I'm like,
nick is just still swinging from the head.
That's my way.
That's my favorite joke.
That that stage is still one of my favorites in the contra.
I don't do Caroline's and own the problem with Caroline's those when they
reduced the stage down to the size of a fucking shoe box.
But you're absolutely adjustable.
Yeah.
But on,
but not like on a Tuesday,
Wednesday night with like 60 70 people in there.
It's amazing.
It is my faith.
I was so comfortable cause I played it so much when I first moved to New York.
I could stay up there for three hours.
I got so much done.
I wrote half specials on that stage by doing like Tuesday nights for a year.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But this is where you get it done.
Yeah.
Right.
You were right.
Like 60 60 people in the crowd.
Fucking around.
Isn't that knocked the fuck them.
I did some little place up in Canada,
Niagara Falls,
the Quanta comedy club.
I'm going to real hole in the wall.
Shitty tables and you know,
fucking just cheesy had the best time on my lunch.
Well when a place is big then it becomes a show and you have to do your ad.
Yeah.
You have to work tight,
which stifles creativity.
Yeah.
That's one of the reasons why Ari,
when he does a store,
he'll sign up for like late night and he'll get on like a 1245 or some shit like
that.
And there's 20 people there.
And I always say that that's like truth serum because if you do your act in
front of 20 people,
you know what sucks?
Like there's no,
no confusing.
What sucks.
It's right in front of.
That's right.
You feel the terribleness of it.
Yeah.
Material.
You don't need 250 people tell you suck.
It takes four couples and paying attention and you just,
but you feel it.
Like you can kind of song and dance your way through a couple of hundred feet.
That's right.
Because even,
yeah,
you're exactly right.
A barometer always said,
give me just double
figures.
Give me 15 to 20 yes.
That is enough.
Right.
Great to work out material.
Of course,
it's great to,
it was to cut out all the Horse Shit in your act,
you know?
Yeah.
Because if there's only 15 people in the room and seven of them don't like the
joke,
oh,
you fail it.
Yeah.
Was the 15 if someone's sitting there with the cross arms staring you down like
yikes.
That's where the work gets done.
Yeah.
I hate,
I used to hate playing Caroline's,
and this is ironic,
but this was when I was,
you know,
had comedy central specials and I was kind of hot and I would sell out
Caroline's,
I would hate it though,
like two shows on a Saturday night cause it's packed.
And I know I have something called the Asshole quotient for every 20 people in
the club is one asshole.
So if there was like 250,
you know,
somebody do the math.
So you got more asshole.
Yeah,
I,
oh,
so you have to work fast and tight to keep their attention as opposed to taking
your time on a Tuesday night in front of 60 people.
And the rail funny comes out when you say shit in between you approving bits.
Yes.
There's the gold.
Yeah.
Right.
It comes out of nowhere.
It's like it opens up and when you,
and you put yourself in that frame of mind to when there's only 30 people,
uh,
you know,
midnight or something like that,
you're putting yourself in a different framework.
There's no pressure.
Well,
what kitten?
Now let me ask you that.
[inaudible] say,
can you do that in front of a full room?
I can't put myself in that mentality.
It's hard because you have to work differently.
I feel like I'm being a pussy and given in,
but I know damn well if I work as slow as I do in front of 40,
50 people in front of two 50 or 300,
somebody's going to get anxious in the yard.
At least that's my eye.
That mentality you said when you show them it's 50 people,
it's almost like fucking around somebodies living room.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And I want that failing in front of 300 people,
400 feet.
It's always different.
You know,
we were talking about that last night.
They'd like when you do a large theater,
it's so much different than doing a club.
Even if you do a pack club of 500 people,
then you move to a place that's got 5,000 people.
It's just a different feeling.
It's a totally different feeling.
You have to do the air quotes act,
you got to do your act,
you know?
Yeah.
It just gets weird.
Large numbers are weird that,
yeah,
timing's different.
You have to,
you can't hammer the punch lines like you can in a club,
like a club,
you go punch.
You remember Gavin would hit him,
punched him enough to punch on the tag,
tag,
tag.
And those tags would just have everybody roll.
Yeah.
Well if he was doing 10,000 people that those tags would get drowned out in the
laps of love of all the people around you.
I tried tag and when I did like my first tonight show,
I tried tag and you know,
and like,
like I said,
got lost there.
Then for a bank,
it's bourbon.
You don't tag like you're in a club.
You know,
I remember learning that lesson maybe,
but you're absolutely right.
Uh,
uh,
Gavin was rapid fire and I remember watching him at Nick's,
I came in when I first started coming and I stepped in the door.
He's on stage and I'm like,
is he dying?
Everybody?
All the,
everybody was doubled over in the audience.
I thought he was fucking done all sudden.
You know,
you couldn't hear any laughed at all sudden a huge draw.
I mean,
cause he would tag,
like you said,
take a joke 11 times and people are still dying from the law.
They were literally bent over,
nothing was coming out of it.
I'm like,
yeah,
I mean he was shaking the roundedness.
Yeah,
I think we got a chance to see some guys that are probably some of the best
comics of all time and people don't know.
You know,
I think with chewing Sweeney and Gavin and Lenny and,
and,
and those guys that we saw when they were in their prime and had a rod,
you're sure.
Yeah.
Kenny,
when we were coming up,
those guys were in their prime and when we were young,
we've got a chance to see,
I think some of the greatest of all time,
no doubt about it.
But they got stuck.
Well the guys at next put them on a contract for a while to remember,
gave them good money and coke.
Yeah.
They,
they will make,
and I remember him telling me they would make three grand a weekend and not
having to leave your city making road money and,
and like you said,
a lot of some parks on the side.
Um,
free booze from all that.
Yeah.
All the but it all live great.
Did they ever,
but uh,
yeah and in the long run,
you know,
um,
well in the long run it was a problem but we got to see some crazy fucking car.
I remember those,
some of those nights and Nick's comedy stop when you watch those guys get,
I won't remember.
Sweeney killing so hard.
You almost wanted to quit comment enough.
There's no way I could do that.
Well,
I have to follow the fucking guy.
Gavin would in Boston back then.
If you know Don Galvin show,
he would be the host swimming.
No Gaddafi the halls.
He would start off the show.
Yeah.
That's a different thing about Boston too,
right?
That's right.
Like if you did the Nick Depaulo show at Nick's comedy stop,
you would just be hard off the shot.
And what was crazy?
It was great,
but young comic,
but I had to follow cabin.
You want a tight 15.
So it made me,
you know,
fucking uh,
it may,
you had to be able to hold your own and they talk at a hundred miles an hour
plus they coked up and they're really,
and they're really funny.
They're really funny.
And they get heavy Boston accents and their big men that like big imposing
people.
Oh yeah.
And they would destroy some guy who came in.
I remember guys something gold.
Ronnie gold from New York.
It just done his first tonight show and shit.
And he was coming to Nick's for the weekend and everybody was dropping in.
Gavin would do 10 chance Lankton when all of his guitar and literally get like a
standing ovation.
He has Ronnie goal five minutes into it.
Cricket,
cricket,
pancreas,
Irish kids would they blond eyebrows get suck.
Yeah,
I remember that.
That was the tough room.
If you are having a bad set,
well they would do it to the people on blood.
They would do it to anybody from out of town that had a big attitude and a
Hollywood resume.
They did it to Billy crystal.
They live Billy crystal up in that room.
Well that I understand.
Yeah.
Well I kind of do what you gotta do it.
They did it to everybody though.
Yeah.
It was crazy to watch.
They were like these guys where's funny as them and we're going to punish them
and they would,
you know who they didn't do it to don my rera.
Exactly.
Don Marrero went up there like a fucking champ and just rode the wave.
Yes.
He just kept that way's going.
Yeah.
I went on comics come home a couple of years ago.
Uh,
no,
not the last,
the one before that.
And Dom had to close the show and it was a murderer's row.
Bobby Kelly Buck and me Billy taking the roof off the dump and I'm like,
dom has to close this and I,
he says funny as anybody,
but I'm just saying,
how's he gonna he goes up there and he did something self deprecating.
It gets a nicely within a minute and a half he had them and there was no drop
off.
There was no drop off in response.
I went,
whoa.
I didn't realize he was that fucking good.
Oh,
he's still that good.
Dot.
My rare has not lost a step.
Brilliant.
Funny Guy at the store all the time.
Yeah.
I quit drinking.
Told me quit drinking for two months.
Very happy for him.
Yeah.
I say he has hand to like check and he had his a nerve issue.
It's actually,
it goes from his shoulder all the way down to his arm.
Yeah.
Mushrooms that'll help him or heard of her.
That's what he said.
Shit.
He told me that's what God damn,
now that you brought it up.
Fuck Dude.
We've been honestly better get you out of here.
I have,
he looked,
I said before,
anytime Joey,
come on,
but I would I,
this is,
I mean this show is pebbles.
Anything else?
PB radio.
And I did that flight.
That just makes me mentally ill.
I get it.
I fucking almost started crying halfway out here.
I just got a guy next to me sucking on a straw like a six year old with ice in
his glass has nothing in it.
It's 110 degrees on the plane.
Baby behind me screaming like somebody who using a soft spot in his head for a
fucking ashtray.
I can't make this shit up.
I almost fucking,
I was almost crying,
but uh,
you know what?
I got to commodity more than once every two years.
Yeah.
I feel have come out.
And next time I've got a show tonight,
the Improv,
but anytime I know,
anytime we ain't come do shows me,
we'll do it being tracked with the rest of the world.
Can I plug a couple of yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Tell anybody where you are.
My,
uh,
my podcast,
just go to nick tip.com and a Monday through Thursday at 6:00 PM Easton.
Uh,
it's streamed live on for free,
a Monday and Wednesdays.
And I just shot a thing called stick men and October to about instructional
baseball clinic that you don't,
you know Adam Ray the comedian?
Yeah,
he's in it.
Okay,
cool.
Andrew Perise,
he wrote it and Andrew's partner already saw some stuff to Netflix,
so we're hoping and it came out killer.
It's called stick men.
It's rarely testosterone.
Drebin so you'd fucking like it.
Nick.
Dip Dot compromise show,
uh,
tonight at the Comedy Palace Sunday night of Ventura harbor comedy club slash
Chinese restaurant.
It's a good spot.
I know.
It's fucking awesome.
And uh,
what am I forgetting?
I know I'm forgetting something.
Uh,
Instagram and Twitter,
all that stuff.
but go to [inaudible] dot com the show is growing leaps and bar.
I'm shooting a special in March at Cohos Hall in New York.
I think I'm just gonna put that one out there.
Use Your,
what you told me?
Just flood the market with it and I've been charged,
but just flooded,
flooded.
Looked it up in front of you all's my standup is still my thing.
All right.
Love you.
Always good to see you.
Same here,
Nick.
Dipaolo ladies and gentlemen.
Woo.
I'm so nervous.